allez salut à tous bienvenue bonsoir
on est parti pour un nouveau draft hoc
avec ce soir le magic au programme vous
avez déjà eu pas mal avec indiana ok ici
et moult encore à venir
pour gagner ce soir on a gagné tant qu'
de magic et faire ça lui gaëtan salut
salut à tous merci pour l'accueil
merci à toi d'être présents qui sera là
pour nous parler du magic vu que let's
go matic que lui est-il un de ceux qui
l'a le plus vu cette année on aguillon
de basket info et de baskets la bassée
qui sera notre expert de la nba salut à
tous je vais essayer en tout cas mais
c'est un plaisir d'être réinvité sur
envergure surtout qu'en plus cette année
je connais pas de prospecter pour éviter
donc c'est très gentil
bas bienvenue à toi et enfin on ne
présente plus the voice cas
l'avis tranché le boul email comment ça
va lui
écoute ça va très comme ce soir donc
plus pour le match grande franchise donc
j'ai préparé un maximum
je dois ma présence au boss parce que je
m'y mette en position de philosophes ce
soir salut alex g je prends une pause
des philosophes du coup je m'amuse
activement le penseur de rodin
merci de ton invitation pierre merci
de l'autre
on va attaquer tout de suite donc on va
garder le même principe on va parler
d'abord de ce qui s'est passé cette
année 2 la franchise d'orlando à prendre
sa trace on va parler essentiellement du
pic à 1 on est en finira par parler un
petit peu des pics 32 et 35 qui sont pas
inintéressants non plus en vue de la
reconstruction du magic
calais temps on va partir avec toi quel
bilan cette année pour l'année un de
mosley et de deux roues qui
en la personne de john suns et monsieur
wagner
nul marche
[Musique]
rapide puis moi j'ai trouvé une bonne
saison une saison excité excitant pardon
en tout cas on sortait la de
saison régulière où on titille un peu
les play-offs on se fait défoncer il y
avait rien de fun dans le jeu on
essayait de défendre mais on défend des
pas on va essayer d'attaquer mandat on
n'attaquait pas fin c'était c'était
vraiment on a passé 5 6 ans là pour les
fans du magic j'en vois plein dans le
chat se fait plaisir on discute souvent
la nuit a galéré devant les matches et
on a eu une saison assez excitante avec
avec coach mots
bien sûr un rookie qui explose celui
qu'on attendait pas forcément mais
avec avec france qui envoie du lourd sur
la saison enfin moi j'ai été surpris de
sa saison je vous laisserai après me
dire ce que vous en avez pensé mais moi
je gj jamais devancé
sur les premiers matches et en
avant-saison dire qu'ils pouvaient
sortir une saison comme ça
envoyez une telle régularité une telle
constance fin
je m'attendais pas à ce niveau là
plutôt déçu de sa muse jane est un peu
déçu là il a loupé pas mal de matches là
plusieurs plusieurs blessures la con il
y en a encore une année il passe même
l'été blessés
je crois qu'il a encore fait mal au
pouce ou je ne sais plus où mes enfants
il est encore blessé après plutôt est
compliqué compliqué le début de saison
avec lui compliquer l'intégration avec
avec cole anthony aller les
responsabilités on sait pas trop à qui
les donner et il y avait françois
gagnaire qui plus est dans un coin
plutôt moi j'ai trouvé qu'il a mis du
temps à trouver sa place
un petit peu un petit peu mieux la sur
son retour de blessure j'ai pas envie de
dire une bêtise mais
je crois qu'il est blessé février il
revient en mars lui fait un gros mois de
mars je vous avoue là que je parle de
souvenirs mais je vous m'arrêtez si je
me trompe et vous savez que je me trompe
mais il envoie un bon gros mois il se
blesse pour la fin de saison
et puis et puis voilà enfin en fini 30e
enfin pas 30e et 15e de la comtesse de
dernier bilan
avec
avec le pyro le pire reaching offensive
de la ligue
la 1re et thing défensif plutôt bon
quand on voit l'équipe le dise le 17e de
la ligue quand on voit l'équipe de
jeunes qu'on avait moi je suis plutôt
surpris suis avec en revoyant les stades
je me dis même d'accord on a quand même
une identité défensive sur certains
jeunes qui est intéressante qu'il faut
sûrement garder il ya des bonnes choses
qui sont faits à orlando il ya encore
deux ans on nous vendait un coach ultra
défensif avec avec clifford et pourtant
on était 20e il ya trois ans 21e il ya
deux ans enfin là on fait mieux avec un
coach qui est pas forcément qui est
rookie et pas forcément réputé pour la
défense
on va se
projeter un petit peu sur la saison à
venir que c'est ce qui nous intéresse
avec
quels sont les joueurs sous contrat les
piques que vous avez un petit peu parlé
déjà donc si on peut commencer à
regarder ça je pense que vous avez pas
mal de caps de mémoire et vous avez
aussi un noyau dur de deux jeunes qui
est assez conséquent
aurait carrément titre ou pas on est sûr
pour l'année prochaine tu dis pas de
bêtises on est sur un truc comme 85
millions garantis ou sur donc un d un
des plus un des plus petits de nba la
sueur sur les prévisions n'a pas mal de
de kapla qui se libèrent garer à risques
est en fin de contrat most of qu'on
arrête de payer lol
robin lopez qu'on arrête de payer aussi
qui est venu une saison qui sera
sûrement pas resigner il y en a pas mal
on a pas mal qui s'arrête on a une
couille denis fine gopher la sueur
maubant bac
qui normalement a été actée donc il
devrait être là
on a une décision à prendre sur maurice
raygner mais qui devrait garder pour un
million huit
selon moi ça bon choix de le garder
après c'est mon avis puis après voilà
comme tu disais le reste 1 un bon noyau
dur de jeunes noirs autour de call
anthony de france très claire de deux
jeunes suns peut-être un jour qu isaac
voudra rejouer au basket et qui s'y
remettra jeu je sais moi non plus je
pense pas eu que
c'est bon il est parti pour écrire des
livres et il ya là où on
n'est pas là pour parler de ça
mais way un nazi pendant la chaise finir
ton propos après je vais lancer guillou
battue m'a perdue donc à toulouse lens
voilà le castrateur est de retour en
studio puisque tu as bu et penser de
cette saison du magic c'était un peu
cette finalement c'est la première vraie
année après qu'ils aient appuyé sur le
boutault
cesta ouest et est c'était combien nom
et deux mois trois mois que la trade
deadline et que finalement il ya eu ces
échanges multiples qui ont fait qu'on a
on peut faire un reset du côté d'orlando
où c'était vraiment y'a pas si longtemps
que ça et ce qui était assez appréciable
je trouve cette année c'est que vraiment
pour sortir deux gros point c'est d'une
part de donner la priorité aux jeunes ça
a été fait en attaque en défense et même
en termes de temps de jeu et deux places
dans la hiérarchie on est clairement sur
essayé de responsabiliser les jeunes
c'est un peu le but du projet même
quitte à délaisser un peu certains
vétérans plus compétents qui pourrait
faire gagner un peu plus de matches mais
c'est pas c'est pas le projet dont il ya
ce côté là de jeunes mis en avant donc
ça c'est bien quand on est dans ce genre
de projet évidemment testé un peu de
voir qu'est ce qu'ils ont dans le vent
pour pas un site ici tous deux ont
abandonné certains projets ou pas
sachant qu'en plus ils ont pas mal de de
très intéressant évidemment et puis le
deuxième point c'est que d'un mine de
rien il ya quand même une certaine
identité défensive dans cette équipe et
pour le coup c'est quelque chose qu'on
peut pas dire de beaucoup l'équipe de
tanking clairement en plus tu là comme
tu dis on a sûrement ils ont fait voilà
on est sur l'année 1 de cette
reconstruction donc c'est assez étonnant
de voir que on a une équipe qui a déjà
une identité défensive et même plus que
l'identité qui fait déjà pas mal quoi
alors évidemment tout est relatif on
parle de pas mal pour des standards de
l'équipe de temps king mais je vois
qu'au niveau du déficit brytting ils
sont à peu près au milieu de la ligue ce
qui est plutôt pas mal et même j'étais
allé regarder j'ai fait un pote cas ce
serait sympa dessus mais ils ont ils ont
un des meilleur line-up défensif de nba
je crois le deuxième maire de line up
défensif bengué parmi les line up avec
pas mal de deux possessions jouer
ensemble deuxième derrière boston est le
secret de cette réussite c'est justement
cette identité défensive autour de deux
schémas qui grosso modo c'est un peu
comme ceux de milwaukee c'est à dire on
protège le panier à tout prix quitte à
autoriser des trois points et le truc
qui est bien et je finir là-dessus c'est
que ce fameux line up c'est pas un line
up avec des rôles players et par line up
avec béria restée par line up avec robin
lopez ou etc sign up de jeunes donc
comme antony jenkins france wagner et la
paire d'intérieurs de qui est pour moi
la satisfaction de cette saison
bonnel carter et beau bamba qui est en
train de devenir des vraiment des très
bons joueurs défensifs qui sont pas
encore au bout de leur potentiel mais on
a enfin de vrais trucs pour cette année
hugues et et alex j'ai mis le lion corps
donc celle et je les vois pas non de
moins de 24 ans du magic il ya fousse
bombe à illzach s'il rejoint un jour il
ya tout va ou kaki qui est inquiet là il
ya colantoni yarnton ya wagner il ya
ceux plus le premier tour de draft
est-ce qu il ya vraiment quelque chose à
construire à partir de cette chose là
est-ce qu'il ya quelque chose qui se
détache de 2 2 chez eux chez ces jeunes
comme futur 2e première option d'une
équipe dont le futur
insurrection près la ligue d'ahlam
invasion allez je vais
pas énormément de joueurs intelligents
je pense que tu prends le cuit des mecs
que tu as donné à part colette tony et
tu peux visiter croisés quand on
fait des balles perdues pour tout le
monde alain cotta tu vois ça d'un seul
coup c'est pas grave vous le donnera ne
s achètent et ça ira très très bien et
qu'on fermait de découpe des ballons moi
j'y peux rien et ouais t'as vraiment
beaucoup de genres libérateur
intelligent france wagner wendat 14
junior même bamba qui est hyper cultivé
très très bien placé c'est pas les plus
gros potentiel vu comme ça mais tu as
une base de projets qui malgré le la
jeunesse
vraiment on va te donner des bases
défensives constance une solidité hyper
hyper intéressante et à des joueurs
comme moi une belle 14e nord qui a
récupéré la très belle dan qui est un
gros potentiel aussi 7 5 fautes draft
qui a jamais eu une porteur de balle
kajeem une bombe meneur à chicago pour
le coup ça c'est une équipe que je
connais un peu mieux donc gelé vu
défendre tout seul pendant des années et
là il peut enfin montré du potentiel
donc c'est un joueur sur lequel on avait
déjà fait une petite croix on l'avait
déjà un peu trop oublié et il peut
montrer des gones a pu montrer tout son
toute intelligence défensive et quand tu
passes de vous beach point de la défense
de pick and roll à wendake carter junior
moubamba a effectivement c'est
un très gros écarts à la fin
alex
pour reprendre ce que disait guillaume
c'est surtout défensivement parce
qu'offensivement tu parles de première
deuxième option
c'est compliqué hein c'est compliqué
offensivement alors après peut-être
qu'il n'y a pas deux
il ya moins d'emphase là dessus du côté
du coaching staff je sais pas trop
évidemment je ne sais pas comment ça se
passe mais quand ugg regardez énormément
le match mais sur ce que j'ai regardé
ces pauvres l'animation offensif est
pauvre
c'est c'est très compliqué de détacher
un joueur de la base arrière pour dire
ce gars là peut être un créateur
secondaires ou tertiaires dans une très
bonne équipe mais en fait je me pose la
question parce que philosophiquement se
pose toujours la question suscite
historiquement
sur une équipe qui veut aller loin en
playoffs et c'est orlando on est
tellement pas là que c'est pas grave
orlando on n'est pas là et et
je pense que cette année qui arrive va
être l'occasion
de voir éclore au moins un ou au mieux
deux personnes qui peuvent faire partie
vraiment après il faut les identifier
correctement mais qui peuvent faire
partie d'une identité de jeu offensive
pour le coup pour le futur mais ça sera
pas une option 1 et probablement pas une
option 2 selon moi
la transition est tout trouvé on en a
parlé d' identité offensive je veux
retourner vers la guérite ans comment ça
joue le magic cette année commence à
jouer pardon c'était quoi qu'est ce qui
était annoncé c'était sur la transition
c'était sur jeu placé
bolduc et sajoo comment
pour reprendre là moi je trouve super
intéressant ce que ce que vous avez dit
et merci je
suis à fond derrière mob en bas sur je
suis fervent défenseur de tout ce que tu
as dit sur mon bourba sur sur ses
placements sur son intelligence est ce
que on n'arrive vraiment pas à analyser
ça moi je vois tous les matches donc je
le vois et j'espère que d'autres gens le
verront voilà le management si vous
m'entendez c'est il faut le garder non
plus pour revenir sur la saison et je
trouve
si pour rejoindre alex moi je me fait
vraiment chier en attaque le placer en
garde à orlando concrètement c'est c'est
moins catastrophique qu'il ya quelques
années il ya trois ans quand on joue
avec vous c'est vite chevannes gordon
toute l'équipe bas là il y avait
vraiment de quoi vomir là on a quand
même eu
une une base défensive qui est
intéressante ça je vous rejoins là
dessus et derrière on a des jeunes donc
on essaye de courir on est je crois la 3
ou 4e équipe qui perd le plus de battles
ans cette année
mais quand bien même c'est pas grave on
essaye de courir on a une bonne pays
est derrière s'est beaucoup de
transition enfin le jeu d'orlando s'est
quasiment que la transition il ya que
des jeunes tu faisais la liste des
jeunes de moins de 24 ans il est épanoui
ça en fait
c'est sur les 48 minutes c'est
ses 38 minutes de deux joueurs qui sont
sur le terrain et qui qui joue qu'au
moins de 24 ans donc effectivement je
pense que je pense que l'idée du
coaching staff et est bonne il faut
courir avait avec des jeunes enfin
vers quoi je vois le titre merci
ça fait trois ans qu'il n'ya rien trois
points oui ça c'est vrai job dans les
commentaires on a eu aussi une des
équipes les plus faibles auront en
termes d' adresse à trois points et je
pense que c'est quelque chose qui est
travaillée et du coup vous m'avez
totalement perdue avec les conneries qui
passe dans le chat je suis désolé je te
vexe reprendre on était sur l'identité
du jeu offensif de caen ans a joué
orlando donc je me mentais vers
guillaume
semblait dans les stades avancés que ce
qui faisait le plus c'est pourtant ce
qui n'est pas forcément le plus efficace
et jouer sur des hand of disent que tu
cette impression là aussi tout à fait et
notamment à notamment autour de moi des
cartes en juniors qui qui depuis a pour
le coup ça c'est une draft que j'avais
fait donc j'avais pas mal étudiée car
tigers en juniors s'étaient alors ford
2.0 qu'enfin il est un peu comme ça dans
la polyvalence défensive dans la
polyvalence offensif notamment que ses
capacités à être notamment en pivot
passé en hyper intéressant cette année
là peut-être même le meilleur passeur de
de cette cuvée de pivot hyper
talentueuse et oui il ya pas mal de en
fait c'est très difficile comment dire
de juger cette attaque parce que déjà on
a le contexte de temps king donc le but
n'est effectivement pas de prendre du
plaisir dans les matchs de que les
matches donne quelque chose de bien quoi
au niveau des stats c'est vrai que il ya
ce qu'on appelle les fours factors donc
les quatre facteurs principaux pour
définir définir une attaque donc
réussite au tir ils sont dans les deux
ou trois derniers temps 9 heures ils
sont dans les 5 derniers rebonds
offensifs ils sont dans la rue dans les
trois derniers et pareil pour les
lancers francs provoquée donc voilà on
n'arrive pas très bien à définir ce qui
est la pire attaque de nba depuis des
années mais le truc aussi c'est que
c'est difficile pour parler un peu du
style de décorréler à quel point décoré
dans le style de la quel point les
joueurs sont pas très bons quoi
finalement et pour le coup je pense que
orlando déjà un peu en avance en défense
avec notamment la paire d'intérieurs
mais aussi avec jonah hex defraggler que
je trouve plutôt très bon en défense
mais voilà c'est on a toujours un peu
cette impression que les équipes de
temps king elle joue mal aussi ou
qu'elles développent pas de jeu parce
qu'en fait à la fin les paniers rentre
pas moi j'ai pas été catastrophé par les
systèmes de genre de même mais c'est
qu'en fait il n'y a pas le talent le
talent est pas encore là et c'est normal
après c'est que mon avis mais je veux
dire tu prends la moitié des
dépossession que tu as vu qu'ils sont
mal terminées tu les fais terminée par
un panier parce que tu as des histoires
talentueux peut-être que tu ressors avec
une impression de dire oui finalement ça
joue pas mal et tout donc voilà il ya ce
côté manque de talent et je suis plus
que c'est qu'en parler aussi et
allemandes de créateurs principale qui
fait que c'est encore plus la débandade
qu'à lire quoi si tu prends par exemple
oklahoma city
ok tu as une équipe qui est pas très
bonnes mais taken by alexander qui peut
un peu faire des choses quoi et même
plutôt des très bonnes choses orlando
tapas a encore sa le créateur principal
ce qui fait que en effet tu te retrouves
avec une équipe qui est pas très
talentueuse pour mettre les paniers donc
licite et non pas leur bien et en plus
c'est un paramètre qui peut te sauver
qui peut créer quelque chose à partir de
rien que ça rend une impression encore
pire quoi
donc encore un gros chantier ou
offensivement on reviendra sur on est
toujours sur l'identité l'identité des
fonds si par contre là tu l'as mis en
valeur tout à l'heure guillaume en
disant tu effectivement c'était mon
équipe de temps king une visite qui est
fondée nu et c'est vrai qu'elle est
qu'elle se situe dans la moyenne nba un
peu les chiffres
ça défend comment sur les surtout sur
pick'n roll
qu'est ce que ça fait ça mais aussi un
peu nous éclairer peut-être sur les tic
qui choisit alors justement je parle un
peu de la comparaison milwaukee pour
pour que les gens aient un peu une idée
en tête on est un peu dans ce style non
c'est à dire non seulement sur pick'n
roll on va défendre plutôt en europe
notamment avec vos bambins qui est qui
et pas un intérieur qui peut switcher de
manière incroyable partout mais qui à
cette présence un peu le potentiel à la
rudy gobert on se dit ça à voir le
niveau mais pas de protecteurs de
paniers qui reste en retrait pour
protéger le panier donc il ya cet
élément là que carter peut faire aussi
d'ailleurs et puis en dehors de ce
positionnement de l'intérieur tu as
aussi plein de deux rotations mais pas
vraiment des rotations c'est aussi des
positionnements de plus en plus agressif
finalement autour de la raquette pour
protéger la raquette à tout prix quitte
même du coc a délaissé parfois certains
shooter à trois points un peu comme
milwaukee un peu comme parfois miami un
peu comme plainds équipe le font de plus
en plus et ce qui fait que tard il a
compensé finalement ton manque de talent
par les mathématiques finalement tu
protèges les plaisirs les plus rentables
du basket qui sont les tirs au panier
effectivement il tente dans le top 10 en
termes de de l'est au panier autorisés
ils seront aussi dans le top 10 en terme
de deux réussites autorisé parce qu'en
plus il est bon protecteur de panier est
donc plutôt que voilà tu donne la
priorité à ces tirs la quitte a autorisé
des trois points et il
a la recette elle marche plutôt bien
autour de ces systèmes vraiment de tout
pour laraque
alors après si si je peux à si je peux
acheter un truc et on n'y a eu beaucoup
de
papiers sur l'efficacité défensive du
magic en deuxième partie de saison qui à
relativiser avec le fait que l'on m'a tu
joues contre des équipes qui jouent pas
tout le temps à fond et c'est un machin
mort première partie de saison si lyon
est sur la deuxième partie de saison il
ya eu un peu plus de switch ils sont
allés un petit peu plus vers meets with
their un peu plus vers une ère une
défense entre guillemets moderne sigean
rien dire mais polyvalente on va dire
voilà polyvalent polymorphe 2-2 et
et ça fonctionnait bien parce que parce
qu'ils ont des bons joueurs pour faire
ça en fait ils ont dit franz wagner a
effectivement été excellent que ce soit
sur les gros porte il m'a vraiment
impressionné sur le sur sa défense sur
les stars adverses parce que c'était lui
qui se les coltiner il a vraiment été
très bon
mais hockey est exclu ouais exactement
j'avais cité tout moi ok qu'est et comme
hub parlé tout à l'heure de joueurs
intelligents en fait c'est une défense
ou vu qu'il ya beaucoup de switch mais
en même temps beaucoup dead il faut des
joueurs qui lisent les rotations très
rapidement et pour le coup ben johnson
autant offensivement c'était dur très
dur à voir jouer cette année autant
défensivement tu sais qu'il est là il
est direct dans le bon timing dans l'es3
on n'a pas encore parlé du budget m
d'ailleurs tu faisais le lire avec milou
qui sait peut-être pas neutre mais le
james et shana monde c'est celui qui est
un peu la sig ateurs de milwaukee
champions 2021
qu'est ce que est ce que vous avez vu ce
qu'il a dit des choses un petit peu de
temps après sur un peu la tagline que le
magic se fixe pour redevenir une équipe
compétitive ce que yahia il ya un projet
il ya une date qui a quelque chose qu'il
faudrait aussi donner des billes quelque
part pour pour la gratte réveillère
moi non je te dis je te donne les vraies
infos les infos qu'ils tournent enfin
je me suis perdu dans ma phrase ouais
non après que comme n'importe quel
j'aime et il va te dire en 7 s 2 ans et
3 ans le projet là il a encore parlé là
au niveau du premier choix de draft de
se dire bon on prend un énorme potentiel
et dans trois ans l'objectif c'est le
titre après c'est pour ça que je te dis
est ce que je te dis ce que j'ai lu ou
est ce que je pense je faisais
ça peut être un peu les deux est ce que
on est reparti sur une reconstruction
vraiment profondeur du côté d'orlando où
s a pour objectif d'être un peu plus
court que d'autres c'est plus ça le sens
de la question en fait
moi je pense qu'on a du temps ça pour
enfin on fera par landreau avant cinq
ans si c'est ça la question en play-offs
en tout cas pinces et je pense qu'il
faut compter au moins cinq ans et ce
quatre bien est-ce qu'il a plutôt dit et
je ressortirai le tweet je l'avais je
l'avait recruté un moment ce qu'il avait
dit c'est que lui en tout cas prendrait
le temps et ça c'est important aussi et
je pense que le proprio va lui laisser
du temps là dessus toi parce qu'ils ont
confiance en lui sont vu ce qu'il a fait
à milwaukee et je pense qu'ils vont lui
laisser du temps la crue
est il qu'il y ait eu des infos aussi
qu'on était par rapport au pic un bien
sûr et
rien qui avait fuité ils ont juste dit
je crois qu'ils allaient prendre
quelqu'un de gros lots ou quelque chose
comme ça
ouais c'est john hammond quoi en gros un
voile at et ça c'est un peu son
historique quoi on revoit un peu un
politique qui équipera été fait par
damon qui avait et ami lou qui est donc
à orlando les sérails qu'il est connu
pour aimer ce profil longiligne avec les
grands bras au fil que hugues mbia aussi
pauvre il ya des johnson larry sanders
je sais pas s'il était là déjà à
l'époque mais oui c'est vrai que chaque
année
lors des castings voilà c'est simple
forcément jamais que du bon est ce qu'il
est et l'aja melvin phrase dire ou pas
oui oui mais voilà
le mec de michigan
matthews non
c'est pas vague non j'ai tourné un autre
mec de michigan aussi très très long qui
joue plus aujourd'hui temps presque pas
grave
il aurait pu faire l'an 2 tu veux dire
non un pic à milwaukee en application
ces derniers jours il joua michigan il a
fait une ou deux saisons après de la
dette pourront pour eux de répondre aux
questions de la timeline je pense qu'un
aliment à prendre en compte c'est que tu
vois par exemple comparer à ok ici
auquel ce qu'ils ont déjà une star
établi avec gi joe alexander ils ont des
rôles players très bon vent même plus
que remplir avec avec lou d'or d'exeter
et surtout ils ont plein de pique donc
tu veux d'ici un an ou deux qui veulent
mettre le paquet de lemaître d'ipic pour
aller chercher je dis n'importe quoi
mais rudy gobert au poids le jeu enfin
papa le changement ou une autre star ils
peuvent le faire parce qu'ils ont le
disons les assets pour faire ça en
landau je crois pas qu'ils aient autant
d'ascète pour faire ça ils n'ont pas non
plus de deux joueurs majeurs établi pour
se dire bon on vise même le moyen terme
quand je pense qu'on est plutôt sur du
long terme
messieurs je pense que là on a fait un
petit peu le tour de la saison du magic
et ses devoirs identifié un petit peu on
a vu qu'ils avaient quand même et encore
ce n'est pas inintéressant mais sam de
mon point de vue en tout cas ça
effectivement
ça manque d'un vrai d'un vrai leader
d'un
soudard j'ai pas cette expression mais
le mâle alpha quoi est-ce que
du coup est ce qu il y a un profil qui
collerait à ça est ce que toi déjà
autrement qu'ils avaient je suis numéro
un dans votre board doit commencer comme
ça
hugues ouais bon dans mon board alors le
board il est fait pour rappeler gens
s'en ressent plus de contexte de kia le
premier choix semble assez de la
philosophie globale tu fais une page
blanche et tu le dis le à moi j'aime me
paolo gontero
gmi palawan bureau comme on l'avait dit
à notre live parce que pour moi c'est le
meilleur créateur individuelles qui
arrivent et qui peut jouer et met 20
points dans une franchise de merde et
construit une attaque autour de lui
effectivement il ce côté madoff pour le
magic
j'ai choisi de 7,1 au grain perso donc
je pense que si je fais une box mais
très jet au magic mais voilà parce que
il ya déjà les autres à des créateurs il
leur manque de l'intelligence défensive
il étonnamment de totalement compatible
à 100% c'est le profil qui kiffent de
ouf il ya la relation de chasles n 5
jours pour développer mais big band
orlando je mets pas en lomé pour orlando
nom alex débrouille toi avec ça
je suis à deux doigts de dire exactement
l inverse si douce attention
numéro un tchèque en grain parce que
parce que je pense qu'il l'est pour une
équipe dans une draft où selon moi il
n'y a pas de superstar de porteur de
balle numéro un même numéro deux c'est
dans des meilleurs scénarios d'une
équipe qui va loin en playoffs
je préfère draft est un gars qui va être
compatible avec le maximum de joueurs
possibles et en même temps élevé bâton
plafond défensif de manière
très très visibles immédiatement
être est en fait augmenter la valeur des
joueurs qui sont déjà présents
et pour moi
théoriquement si tu veux améliorer
orlando et que tu veux joue les
play-offs l'année prochaine peut-être
que c'est mieux d'avoir le bon de
chéreau
maintenant à long terme je pense que
c'est mieux d'avoir cetto une graine
parce que jason grain tu peux le mettre
l'année prochaine il va être très bon
défensivement il faut pas négliger que
offensivement il sait faire plein de
choses qui n'a pas montré cette année à
gonzaga parce qu'il était dans son rôle
et
il va laisser la place
à tous ces joueurs qui sont sur les
lignes arrières aux suns au col anthony
omarkheil feltz de grandir d'acquérir de
la valeur au pire et au mieux de devenir
ce que je disais au début des piliers
sur lesquels commencé à construire une
identité offensif
donc je pense que cetto m'bengue rennes
serait mon choix numéro un aussi pour
orlando
et il est mon choix numéro 1 globale
donc ça tombe bien
je vais finir
gaëtan
quel est le choix des fans du magic j'ai
cru comprendre que c'étaient chet et en
tout temps en france
c est ce que c'est y est à 80%
ouais ouais ouais ouais carrément tu
peux me mettre un peu plus moi tous les
gens qui j'en ai parlé c'est fait à fond
et il n'y a pas de question
les mecs ils ont fait déjà 40 saint
martin c'est un truc d'où votre
communauté les tous les maillots jet de
toutes les couleurs orlando magic était
déjà numéro
ça et c'est étonnant que ce côté
dynamique parce que le côté une cage
dans les médias us c'est c'est pas le
nom qui revient le plus souvent c'est on
entend beaucoup de diambars est
d'ailleurs maintenant dans le chat je
vais jouer qui le mentionne et c'est
vrai que
jabbari c'est un nom qui revient
beaucoup et marc semo champion qu'il est
à la fois aimer et
pas trop c'est à dire qu on l aime bien
mais on le voit pas en numéro 1
pourquoi jabbari est-ce que diab harissa
vous ferez vraiment hérisser les poils
les fans et magic
ouais moi non moi je suis je suis à fond
sur chet et
j'espère qu'on ira là dessus sur tout ce
que vous avez dit je vous rejoins moi je
rejoins beaucoup alex sur sûre il va
laisser le temps au plus haut ou plus en
cinq lui mais aux joueurs de lignes
arrières à prendre leur place et je
pense que le talent qui va être leur
orlando bat on l'a déjà mais il n'a pas
encore éclos
je sais pas encore qui c'est est ce que
ça sera fond qu'est-ce que ce sera paul
anthony ou est ce que ça sera fondre
hagner
ça sera en tout cas je pense qu'un des 3
va va éclore et il faut pas lui mettre
quelqu'un dans les pattes et surtout pas
déjà baril enfin selon moi
alors c'était un choc il y avait des
boeufs look et le renouveau permet de
faire dans cette vidéo c'est un site est
bien peu de bleu et là
[Rires]
on va repartir on va on refera une
présentation de deux piétonnes vu que
c'est un peu le l'idole des jeunes du
côté du magic
donc hugues présente succinctement et de
façon
détaillée en même temps
et c'est de faire ça je le sais parce
que je
sais que tu ne t'en donne rien le même
et non maintenant que même le faire dès
ce soir nos cieux cet homme est jeune
c'est un intérieur américain que
beaucoup de gens ont découvert avec le
19 équipes américaines qui a tapé
l'équipe de france en finale li fé mal
or il est pointé à 2 13 de 16
c'est un joueur avec un physique nous
les gens se moquent beaucoup parce qu'il
fait très très faim très faim là l'air
très très frêle effectivement dans les
chiffres là nous on l'a si je dis pas de
bêtises je vais prendre les chiffres
envergure parce que y'a qu'ça d'vrai
on la voit 88 kg
donc effectivement il en début d'année
nous pour l'instant n'a pas
d'actualisation là dessus on attendre
sachant que au combat n on n'a pas fait
comme les joueurs top 3 il se présente
pas vraiment il faudra vraiment faire
les mesures extrêmes vont pas faire les
masses musculaires les masses
graisseuses et tout donc on n'a pas
d'actualisation là dessus mais les
franchises nba le son beaucoup de gens
ont critiqué sa sa minceur mais c'est un
joueur qui a montré qu'il était capable
d'en que c'est du contact au niveau n 6
et il a terminé à plus de 90 % sous le
cercle il a fait 3 comprend match donc
ça je retiens pas peur du contact et qui
a vraiment bien encaissé sa
mobilisation de la mobilité dans le
chatt mobile points d'intérêt de sa
taille oui alors c'est pas un jour tu
vas faire l'essuie-glace un corner
corner et cetera mais ils bougent quand
même mieux que les petits veaux
moyenne nba qui 60 kg c'est un joueur
qui a montré déjà qu'ils pouvaient
marquer à tous les niveaux c'est pas un
joueur qui va dans la création de son
propre tir est pour ça aussi que bientôt
on nous disait j'ai pas envie d'enlever
des ballon de la main de challenge
colantoni marque alfa tct c'est tout
effectivement t'as pas un croqueur de
ballons mais un mec qui peut finir au
peigne un rôle qui peut finir en catch
and shoot à mi distance que tout à trois
points voilà groothuis défensif bon
passeur vraiment la licorne moderne
comme on aime bien comme on aime bien la
voir est un joueur qui peut à terme
changer ton équipe des deux côtés du
terrain défensivement bien sûr pour sa
protection cercle sa mobilité et
offensivement par sa polyvalence et à
tout faire sur un terrain de basket
howie du profil guillaume comment ça
s'insère dans le magic est ce que ça
colle laisse que le fit de sambo
c'est toute la question parce que c'est
un peu le problème de d'avoir une équipe
qui a déjà une inde et but d' identité
défensive avec une raquette ou taggia de
non pas deux piliers mais ces deux
jeunes importants qui ont de la valeur
dans la franchise donc moi j'avoue je
posais un peu la question de ce point de
vue là je voulais un peu avoir votre
avis aussi
parce que en temps tu peux te dire aussi
est ce que tu vas plus tôt drafté au
profil même si je pas trop de cet avis
mais est ce que finalement si tu
considères que c'est quoi ces jaden ivy
c'est ça le meneur qu'on annonce dans le
top 4 voilà tu as aussi la question de
si finalement tu crois vraiment à paire
d'intérieurs et que tu en plus dans le
même temps tu évalues janan arrivé comme
potentiellement un porteur de balle
principal je pense que ça peut être
envisageable de partir sur une action
comme ça alors peut-être pas envie qu'un
peut-être que tu descends en deux ou
trois pour avoir récupéré des assets je
sais pas mais je pense à peut être
envisageable parce que tu as cette base
défensive de deux joueurs qui sont très
jeunes qui avaient à l'époque il ya
l'époque il ya quatre ans un potentiel
défensif très grand ils sont en train de
commencer à le montrer donc il ya ce
côté on peut drafté via le profil pour
conserver cette paire d'intérieurs mais
en même temps et c'est là où je vous
renvoie la balle parce que je la
question c'est de savoir en même temps
si vraiment c'est comme hugues la dcri
un jour une licorne et un talent
générationnel même temps oui tu peux pas
le laisser passer quoi et si vraiment
c'est un jour de cet acabit se séparer
de nos bambins ou devienne une monnaie
de carter bon c'est pas top mais si
vraiment ces pouvoirs et de la place les
données de la place à un joueur qui est
générationnel équine licorne ah oui tu
le fais parce qu'en plus il va récupérer
des trucs en retour quoi tu vas pas le
perdre pour rien mon bamba donc c'est
pour moi la question que j'ai pour vous
c'est est ce que vraiment on est sur un
très bon ou est ce que oui ça vaut le
coup de mal gré d'avoir des gens qu'on a
déjà en place de draft est quand même le
mec qui via qui va sur la même position
moi je pense pas qu'il est moi je pense
que c'est une licorne mais je pense pas
qu'il est générationnel d'accord
pour ça tu vas attendre l'année
prochaine pour avoir un joueur de ce
type la france
mais
chez tonnes de graines je pense qu'on
sous estime et
ai eu qu à parler de ses limites
offensives maintenant mais je pense que
c'est un joueur qui est capable un petit
peu de créer pour lui même je je je je
pense qu'il en a pas juste pas eu
l'occasion
en nba mais tu vois des possessions
ou bien il fait du evans mobley ou assis
plus ou moins c'est-à-dire prises de
balle un ou deux dribbles et je vais
réussir à me créer de l'espace parce que
mon shoot par très haut parce que j'ai
un très bon placement de mes appuis et
parce que je sais gérer le contact sur
le haut du corps malgré le fait que je
sois que je sois un peu frêle
donc il ya cet aspect là maintenant moi
je suis d'accord avec toi sur le fait
que si tu crois que djédjé n'diaye et
il y a l'air d'avoir des gens qu'il le
croit
dans les sphères nba hier en tout cas
proche si tu penses que c'est lui
qui par milo de la draft a le potentiel
pour être option 1 ou 2 en tout cas un
au début et peut-être deux dans une
équipe qui va très très haut
moi je pense qu'il faut le prendre moi
je pense qu'il faut le prendre en
sachant que
tu seras quand même pas bon l'année
prochaine
et que à la draf 2023 déjà des navy ou
potentiels jedi vie pour moi il y en a
plus de 1 ou 2 on a trois quatre
mais du coup si tu prends et vite tu
descente pour la draft tu piques pas
savoir quand même mais là en fait pour
un gmc hypercompliqué fin vous allez me
répondre tous les deux mais si le large
et attrayant
cette baisse est un peu ce qu'ils ont
fait oui c'est de savoir en fait où est
ce que 20 cas la valeur importe les
autres james site pour toi ivy tu penses
que tu peux l'avoir en 4 mai que le mec
de houston où le mec de doc et s'ils
pensent que heavy c'est le 2ème 3ème
larges oreilles tu le prends devant vous
mes seins poker menteur tu réagis jamais
vraiment savoir ce qu'il ya sur le board
des autres équipes donc c'est ça aussi
le truc c'est très bonne ça arrive très
rarement et il faut que tu sois sûr que
ton joueur auquel tu crois fort ils
partent pas avant ou après et ça c'est
hyper rare que cela baisse juste une
place ça sert quasiment jamais rien
parce que pour vous du coup pendant le
top 3 il n'est pas
il n'est pas bloqué
c'est pas c'est pas ben de chéreau
jet et déjà marie c'est pas nous en tout
cas
selon notre avis qui ne vaut rien dans
les sphères un oublié encore une fois
dire mais dans l'est c'est vrai c'est à
dire qu'on peut dire nous selon nous ce
que disait alan la dernière fois c'est
plus une course à 5 ou à quatre ça
dépend des membres du groupe que qu'une
course à trois
même s'il reste on les place pas sur les
mêmes niveaux sur les mêmes tiers mais
en gros si tu veux prendre des fort
potentiel avec un plancher quand même à
peu près correct c'est une course à au
moins 4 voire 5 situé inclus sheridan
chars voire six si tu penses que edge et
griffin peut revenir au niveau auquel il
était au niveau physique je parle auquel
il était au lycée
le fameux podium des 5 alors pour vous
c'est
donc
mais en fait on ne peut pas savoir ce
qui se passe en nba tu vois on ne peut
pas se dire en tout cas ce qui sort sur
haïti c'est que quand même il ya des
équipes du top 3 qu'il aime bien donc
donc c'est sûr il n'ya pas que ça après
le la rumeur jabbari elle vient pas de
nulle part non plus ça veut dire qu'il
ya des des exec descat authier d'une
hache un 10 bat nous on a l'impression
que l'est le magic qu'ils adorent
jabbari et qui vont prendre personne
l'autre mais ça peut être du bluff 100%
en fait on n'en sait rien
c'est aussi la période des smocks screen
période consacrée
que j'ai trop lancé sur le profit on n'a
pas parlé le profil psychologique un
petit peu de chet parce qu'on l'a vu et
entendu surtout passé récemment au
sortir des déclarations qui ont pu être
un peu sur un tertre été mal interprétés
c'est un peu aussi les deux c'est ce
dont j'ai envie de dire non à chaque
année rappelle de l'année yao ming à
l'année d'avant il y avait encore pour
des joueurs comme ça qu'on entend un peu
plus à un mois de la draft comment on
analyse
j'aime bloc c'est un joueur qui a
beaucoup d'autodérision alors oui on
s'enfonce et l'éclatement mais tout le
monde lui dit tu es trop maigre lui dit
vous inquiétez pas je mange et la raison
de le faire c'est le jeu si tu lui dises
l'été promet guy te dis pas non plus eux
qui te disent quoi c'est à dire est ce
que tu peux battre cavendish va pas te
dire non il va m'éclater enfin c'est pas
c'est pas la mentalité qu'il a donc
c'est parce qu'il faut montre en ce
moment à lille a tout à fait raison de
rentrer là dedans c'est un joueur on a
pu le voir à gonzaga il a accepté de
donner des ballons aux joueurs qui
étaient plus expérimentés on pense à des
outils millions pour s'éteindre ou
neymar ya pas eu de souci pour lui là
dessus tout en prenant ses
responsabilités
défensivement dans les moments clés tout
en prenant ses responsabilités aux tirs
dans les moments clés en n'hésitant pas
à prendre des gros shoots en transition
à trois points qui a 10 ans et aurait
été prohibées totalement donc c'est un
mec il ya toujours su s'adapter à la
situation qu'il ya vraiment un discours
très formaté déjà professionnel qui a
mené son équipe à différents niveaux
lycéens 19 ou ainsi et au meilleur
niveau
moi j'ai pas de j'ai pas de problème
avec ça je trouve ça vraiment même kulti
qui rentrent dans cette île débat là
qu'ils ont dans ces provocations à la
con parce que ça fait du clic donc la
journée à une journée d'action comptant
et lui ça lui donne de la visibilité
donc si tout bénef 3 pour lui
en fait un joueur qui veut être le
meilleur il doit penser en fait personne
n'a fait chier mbappé parce que les
déclarations altran corti deux ans après
même bape et quand il dit est pas
content triplé c'est exactement ce genre
de mentalité en fait si tu veux être le
meilleur du monde tu dois penser que tu
es le meilleur du monde et qui a le bape
et l'audit chez tonnes de graines l'audi
et peut-être que ce sera pas le meilleur
certainement que ce ne sera pas le
meilleur parce qu'il en a qu'un mais si
tu ne penses pas t'as aucune chance de
l'être alors que si tu le penses tu à au
moins une petite chance
est ce que ce qui dessert pas entre
guillemets un petit peu l'image qu'on
peut avoir de chet en tout cas
est ce que oui ils m'ont porte je me
suis trompé mais henri parent pour les
observateurs ce qui ment pas un petit
peu de ce qu'il n'y a pas un manque de
charisme un peu chez chip chip
campground
le profil du corps ce pic du mét ya une
grosse confiance en lui la pression
c'est plus naturel par exemple qu'on a
entendu aussi mathurin avoir de
déclarations ou voilà il se pose un peu
comme le guerrier alors je pense à lui
parce qu'il joue à bono dans le 4 mai
voilà donc est ce que il n'ya pas un
petit peu ce biais là qu'on pourrait
aussi tu pourrais nous faut c'est un
petit peu ce qu'on pense de lui même
parce que tu as lu sa tête face à ret
qxc il me ressemble tu vois ce qu ils
soient cotées en donnant une relève 40
cm tumaco t on qui nous met des
calculatrices texas instruments on
dirait qu'on programme en première s tu
vois juste lire el bey sur la
calculatrice donc c'est effectivement
c'est pas vendeur il a une pomme d'adam
l'acquis qui ressort on dirait qu'ils
roland garros qu'il avait le ballon à la
balle bon ok mais mature à côté il a
inhalé il a un sourire flash il a des
bonnes pommette jabbari ce missile et
l'hyper arrogante is toujours une bille
est donc oui ça le dessert mais à côté
de ça je pense que les franchises nba
devons faire des interviews où elles
vont tester plein de trucs manteau elles
vont garder la compétitivité du mec et à
la fin qui soit beau pas très très beau
c'est pas très grave c'est disney sea et
spillane houleux mais train un chapeau
gigantesque des oreilles yeux comme ça
et ça fera quatre ans regarde les gens
centre actif et on prendra quand même du
maillot vous inquiétez pas
j'aurais bien aimé du coup si vous
essayez un peu le pur pour constituer un
peu si vous pour le comparer à d'autres
prospects
générationnel mais deux des tops rospez
hurler sur le poste de poupe des années
précédentes par exemple face à eva de
meublés ou ce genre de profil comment
est ce que vous le situer est ce que
vous préférez meublés ou home green j'ai
pas de tenir tête notamment tous les
pivots la classe 2018 en effet le fameux
et hilton bamba et c est ce qu il est
plutôt au dessus ou en dessous de ceux
là exc ou est ce que vous le situer sur
les draft on va dire des dix dernières
années ou des cinq dernières années à
quel point ce que vous le mettez au dans
cette hiérarchie
offensivement je pensais le meilleur
de tout ce que tu as cité et
défensivement deuxième derrière mobile
est pour moi ok
est ce que vous aimez déroulé il ya
souvent cesseront de comparaison souvent
je sais pas mais c'est une comparaison
chez lui l'eau tout cas de la
comparaison en grain mobile est ce que
c'est pas de désastre comme
c'est pas c'est pas cool pour
pour un brin défensivement parce que me
vient de faire une saison 2 vous falloir
moi j'ai passé la dernière attaque les
va doubler sur des chaussures des points
la plupart ma femme et ma bouche je suis
très content pour les fans des cases et
pour julien aussi qui peut se venger
d'un autre dans notre foi de sape mais
chattam grain s'il arrive à faire un
tout petit peu que ce que fait ma demie
le vocable c'est très cool et encore une
fois mobility mère d'une défense avec un
autre grand pivot hyper protecteur de
cercle avec de la zone avec une idée
défensive et on peut souhaiter que la
même chose pour pour cent et l'avantagé
que s'ils tombent au magic ce que je
souhaite aux fans du magic vi dans les
commentaires y sont à fond qui est 10e
parlons maintenant du 32 35 comprendre
sièges
c'est que au magic tu vas avoir
effectivement gwendal carter jr qui
pourra défendre du 4 qui pourra défendre
du 5 plus épais du mot bomba [ __ ]
robin lopez qui reste en vétérans donc
tu as un vrai contexte idéal pour
développer toujours chant plusieurs
styles de jeu très bien oui je pense que
je pense que c'est passe pas on pas
avoir la tente du evans mobley année un
défensivement même si le magic ce serait
vraiment un des meilleurs contexte
défensif pour chat comme disait
maintenant
je pense que la limite de piques 17 en
grain 1
c'est celle que donne et josh moisins
lors de nous tout premier live ok si et
qui disait
je vais virer le bot vite et
j'ai cliqué sur le lien fois ça m'a
vendu du rêve comme ça je me suis dit
voilà est en fait je touchais tongren ça
vaut pas le coup les gars
je pense que cet homme graines n'est pas
un joueur auquel il faut donner un
contrat max en règle générale si tu veux
aller chercher un titre et si c'est ton
si c'est ton on dira ton objectif à long
terme ce qui est ce qui est à peu près
le cas de toutes les franchises nba
théoriquement
il ya ce côté situe le draft en premier
et qui ensuite tu en fais un ton joueur
majeur et que tu lui donnes le max et c
est ce que ça va pas te bloqué dans son
développement à long terme mais je sais
pas à quel point cette théorie elle est
valable ça serait une question
intéressante pour point guillaume mais
est ce que tu penses guillaume qui a
des joueurs les joueurs que tu dois de
rester tout en haut de la draft sont
forcément du coût des options hyper
hyper forte et qu' on
ne devrait pas drafté des joueurs qui ne
peuvent pas être dans ton top un an et
demi de d'une équipe qui joue en attaque
tu veux dire que non oui on attaque oui
bah ouais alors non je pense pas
forcément en fait il ya deux choses pour
moi c'est que la draft est un livre on
s'en rend pas compte mais il ya un taux
de réussite qui était extrêmement faible
au niveau des prospects et encore plus
pour on parle même pas de devenir un bon
joueur on joue en nba de rotation de
vraiment devenir un top joueur une
superstar ou sur un truc probabilité
très faible donc si vraiment tu penses
que tu en a un avec migraines et moi je
le connais pas mais je vous fais
confiance sinon tu penses pour moi il ya
oui tu le prends et le fait que ça soit
pas ta première option en attaque c'est
pas grave moi je veux dire si rudy
gobert six fois le définitive sur steam
et ses défenseurs
générationnel justement ce genre de truc
de raimon green ce genre de mec pour moi
ça me dérange pas en fait c'est ça me
dérange pas de prendre ces mecs là
plutôt que d'aller tenter un pari sur
deux que de plus de pardon de préférer
un mec en attaque parce que c'est un
porteur de balle mais qui va être moins
fort quoi clairement je préfère pas
après ce qui est vrai aussi c'est que de
l'autre côté le l'endroit où tu as plus
de chances de stopper ses joueurs
notamment qui sont excellents en attaque
c'est justement la première place de la
draft donc là plutôt que de parler d'un
jeune jeu le jeu il ya aussi la question
de jane année à heavy que du coup je
connais pas donc je m'en remets un peu à
vous mais si tu penses que dans le même
temps déjà des na'vi est aussi de ce
calibre si tu penses qu'il est de cet
acabit et qu'il peut être un porteur de
balle créateur un peu à la diam brent en
fait oui tu tues je peux comprendre le
raisonnement de se dire je vais plutôt
partir sur le porteur de balle que sur
le défenseur parce que c'est plus facile
ex terme' mais pour répondre à ta
question non je pense que si tu penses
vraiment que tu as un joueur qui est qui
va être une super star qui va naître un
olivier pour moi non tu hésites pas en
fait tu le prends parce qu'il a
tellement peu quoi
je crois que gates encore une question
qu'on fasse à d'autres prospects ouais
du coup moi j'avais plus une question
sur on n'a pas du tout parlé mais on est
sur un sur un gars qui fin c'est un peu
pour reprendre ce que disent et alex tu
as tout à l'heure qui a un profil un
petit peu moderne sur un intérieur
moderne où est-ce qu'on en est pour lui
de son dribble
sur ce qu'il est capable de monter un
ballon parce que oui on voit derrière
moi j'ai vu que dialect de lui j'ai pas
vu un match on le voit il monte des
ballons il il peut poser un dribble il
peut dribbler mais ce qui peut
réellement le faire ce qui peut
réellement le faire en nba donc ça c'est
la première question et du coup
peut-être avoir votre avis sur la
deuxième c est ce qu on s comprend pas
un risque d'avoir un deuxième bambin en
le draft en cinq ans plus tard qu'ils
étaient enfin un petit peu le même
profil quoi moment baril avec un profil
défensif avec un potentiel en main en
attaque et au final on voit ce qu'on a
maintenant
donc voila un petit peu les deux
questions que j'avais mon bamba déjà je
vais pour chacun smart qui est un des
pires coach and see donc de son
développement ce que tu aimes crâne ma
poche je suis d'accord
ravasi alex dit des trucs intéressants
maintenant parce que moi
non moi je moi je pense que mon bon bah
tu lui dis au revoir assez court terme
par contre
oui bah pour le coup moi c'est sur six
ans le jeune karim c'est c'est le bamboo
la fin de l'année il pu la lui il en est
où de son contrat mais
je crois qu'au define gopher ah oui
parce que parce qu'il a fait une bonne
saison c'est dommage de se priver de la
valeur de la saison qu'il a faite où tu
peux sans doute récupérer je suis pas un
force protéger 2025 qui on sait rien
pour le moment battu
mais quelque chose dans le genre mais
oui c'est une draft cette jeune jett est
beau bamba peuvent jouer ensemble parce
que tu sais tu peux aller chasser des d4
etc mais
mais dans l'ensemble à terme c'est mieux
d'avoir chet en 5 et de le faire jouer
avec wendel carter
surtout si tu gardes cet esprit offensif
à ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure faire
beaucoup de end of etc moubamba
franchement offensivement à part ce pays
c'est ce qu'il a commencé à faire pour
moi c'est très limité tu vois très très
limité
à perm plus avec avec gwendal
ça n'existe pas un 5 défensifs avec avec
bamba et lui
ben en fait je suis pas sûr qu'il soit
plus défensif que avec wendel et lui
donc donc à choisir à choisir tant au
niveau de la mobilité aussi est ce que
parce que vous compariez van mullem il
est pas un peu moins mobile que mob les
hommes
si oui donc tu peux pas aussi facilement
faire des line-up malléable quoi je lis
non mais enfin il compense très bien il
est très longue quand même donc
oui les quatre ultra mobile et qui se
compte pas non plus enfin tu vois qu'ils
sont pas non plus si nombreux que ça
aujourd'hui
mais le problème ce n'est pas de faire
face à d4 mobile c'est faire face à des
looks and cheats qui te switch tré tré
young et c'est à quoi il va le garder en
fait il va te descendre il va tendre
vraiment les bras ce que mobily fait
très très bien donner une direction
c'est qui va te dire bah moi je vais te
donner malling gauche mon bras il fait
de mettre 30 donc je vais te cacher
toute la vision avec mon bras et à
chaque mois par la gauche était
globalement c'est que pas de le contenir
ma terre mon oncle a dit viens donc
c'est ça qui font un maximum les caves
et c'est ça que l'huile a pu faire aussi
à un contrat qu'a donc ils mentent izay
longueur de brad il tutoie pour toi il
est il à la mobilité suffisante pour
faire ce genre de truc un peu comme
comme doublé comme le robert williams
parfois et c'est quoi pour toi il a il
est assez mobile il switch pas il va
aussi en europe qu'un jean gaubert ils
peuvent être un retournement entre 2 et
à mettre une pression et redescendre à
un petit peu après que ça je le vois
bien le faire moi et le biais assez
rapide ouais moi je me suis d'accord
avec une je le mettrais pas au niveau
d'un rudy gobert mais évidemment pas au
niveau d'un robert williams qui fait
raquette corner en 05 secondes
sur la porteuse pour le dribble vite
fait
c'est peut-être son plus gros point
faible effectivement c'est ce qui était
le plus mis en avant c'est que c'est pas
un joueur qui va faire steinbach et ce
serait inquiétant sinon enfin ce serait
n'importe quoi mais
oui tu le veux le voir prendre des
rebonds remonte en transition dégaine à
3,36 et ouvert ça il le fait sans aucun
problème et après jour sur troll il
n'aime pas qu'on attaque son dribble
mais il peut partir - droite et la spin
move pour revenir et il peut faire rien
vraiment maîtriser comme evans mobley
terminé main gauche déjà terminé ma
droite il peut changer demain pendant
son dribble un minimum donc ça va être
un mec que tu va optimiser chaude du
roll up et si jamais tu sautes sur klose
autant pop qui peut poser un peu le
ballon soit les finir au cercle soit
utilisa décalage pour trouver une bonne
passe parce que c'est un bon passeur qui
comprend bien que ces insectes
l'utilisent et en complément tu
l'utilisé aussi en transition
complètement du jeu tu lui dis mains
libres quand tu prends un rebond qu'à
une ligne devant toi remonte le ballon
parce que tu es une menace qu à partir
de 8 me de 8,9 mètres et une menace en
ampoules up en transition il ya une stat
hyper intéressante où il est vachement
plus efficace
sur les trois points transition que sur
demi terrain
et du coup c'est déjà une menace en
transition en fait que ce qu'il arrive
après un trailer ou qu'il arrive avec le
ballon et je pense qu'au niveau du
dribble tu peux tu peux largement lui
demander de faire ça ce qui va encore ce
que disait gates est en tout à l'heure
c'est une équipe qui court beaucoup
quand même bien courir ça va que
avantage et on efficacité offensive
puisque la transition c'est une des
faces des plus efficaces dans une
attaque nba toute façon
je pense qu'on a fait tour pour jet pour
des questions on a été je crois
exhaustif pas forcément très concis mais
exhaustif et va passer au prochain avec
le favori de muguet hollobone gayraud
d'ailleurs je sais pas comment on dit
ses pompes et robben chéreau s'il ya des
italiens dans ichat dit nous comme on
dit pena glisse patrick karam sens il
paraît
je vois la référence
que tu ne fais encore une présentation
dont tu as le secret bon le bon terreau
ton coup de coeur ouais
alors moi j'ai su que j'étais bonne
qu'elle n'est pas du tout la bonne
langue dramatique et
rapallo bonne quiros et 1 on est plus
sur un profit un peu plus petit beaucoup
plus large on est chauds du 2 0 6 113 kg
donc les plus larges l'udc pour le coup
qu'un pivot nba un physique qui peut
rappeler un peu du lustre en deuil si on
veut maintenant dans la comparaison
c'est un joueur qui est arrivé à user
d'une équipe comme d'habitude et du coup
très jeune mais qui a été le leader
offensif immédiatement de l'équipe il a
pris 150 tiers de plus que le deuxième
joueur qui a pris le plus de tirs à
double lame ans a été lui qui a été mis
en avant c'est un joueur s'il va faire
beaucoup de dommages en isolation un
nouveau mec pour le goût qui aime bien
prendre le ballon et se créent soit
depuis la ligne à trois points mais
surtout de piles postaux avec d
isolation et des fondamentaux au niveau
des pieds exceptionnelle des diab step
qui me rappelle les grandes heures de
carmelo entre autres
à un gars trop puissant pour la une si
elle qui a vraiment dominé physiquement
ya peut-être une question là dessus je
me niveau nba quand on va lui offrir une
opposition athlétique stylo jendoubi
comment est-ce qu'il va gérer parce
qu'on a vu un joueur qui pouvait être
mis en défaut lorsqu'on lui est un gros
tank dessus chansons de riz blé qui
avait tendance à beaucoup poule à
pamiers distance ce n'est pas une vie
moderne
et pour le coup si tu prends hollobone
qui regroupe les dix tués soit que du
pré du 5 soit du 3 points battu limites
clairement le joueur ce serait stupide
c'est un gars qui a montré qu'ils
pouvaient maintenant qu'à tous les
niveaux près du panier à mi-distance ma
trois points faut juste qu'il fasse
confiance en son tir il ya une
comment attirer une
commande une manie motrices un peu
particulière chez paulo banshee dans le
détail vite fait c'est que c'est un
joueur qui shoote mieux lorsque le
ballon arrive sur sa main gauche jeter
sa main faible pour repasser -3 été
déclenchée plutôt qu'au ballon sur sa
main droite ce qui est vraiment très
très rare chez once il est donc ça
montre aussi le tas un gars qui a besoin
de poser un peu le ballon au sol pour
pouvoir se mettre en rythme et tirer à
trois points donc voilà mais
défensivement beaucoup critiqué parfois
trop critiquer je trouve paris
lesbiennes qui voit vraiment voulu faire
sa tête de turc au money sait pas
défendre sa un poulet il ya un manque de
motivation évidente il ya un manque de
latéralité par rapport aux extérieurs
pour switcher là on n'y est pas c'est
vrai mais il ya un second rideau
intéressant il ya une puissance il ya
une capacité verticale ya un timing de
contre qui sont pas sous-estimer donc
voilà je pense que tu as un joueur qui
peut arriver rapidement prendre le
ballon créé de l'attak et est-ce que
c'est efficace je ne sais pas mais en
tout cas ça marque des points quitte
comment guillaume et guettant sa pour s
intégrer ce jour de profil dans le match
il m'a dit
vas-y
vas-y jeu tant que je t'en prie ton
équipe ok bah moi surtout ce que tu as
dit hugues je pense que ça s'intègre pas
du coup c'est c'est plutôt le contraire
de ce qu'on va rechercher selon moi
c'est purement encore mon avis fans
habitant en france j'ai aucun contact
avec le management mais mais ouais je
pense que je pense que ça s'intègre pas
trop quoi
je pense justement qu'on a déjà trop de
gars qui ont besoin de la balle trop de
gars qui pose des dribbles
on perd déjà assez assez de ballons
comme ça on peut dans des dribbles alors
si on continue à en perdre ça réussit
pas moi j'ai du mal à le voir après je
te connais très peu moi je vous parle de
joueurs même thiêt à part lire un peu
des articles et voir des vidéos j'ai pas
vu grand chose mais j'avoue que je me
suis pas trop posé dessus mais j'ai du
mal à analyser a contrario je me suis
plus intéressé à jabbari parce que ça en
parlait aux us et je le vois peut-être
un peu plus que entre 7 et 10 à paris
mais voilà pas du tout bougé
moi je les ai vus un peu parce que j'ai
regardé quelques matchs de kansas city
quand même donc j'ai pu voir un peu à
quoi il ressemblait non non non je crois
je connais pas non plus que j'ai vu que
une mi temps mais ça m'a sur ce que dit
il parce qu'il me semblait aussi que la
défense c'est quand même plutôt pas mal
au niveau du positionnement etc mais du
coup et qu'est ce qui pourrait faire au
magic mais apporter des points de la
création d'après ce que vous en dites
donc ça c'est bien après la question
c'est quel point et son plafond avec
parce que on voit quand même un constant
nba c'est que ça devient très compliqué
d'être un point focal offensif à une
billet sur le poste d'intérieur si tu
n'es pas un créateur d'élite on voit
qu'elle ayant quitté qui peuvent le
faire mais ni au kitsch et à moitié un
porteur de balle un peu dans le
périmètre nbi peu le fer etc mais on se
rend compte que finalement si t'es pas
quelqu'un de d'ultra élite c'était juste
moyen ou bon c'est parfois ce n'est pas
suffisant quoi je prends l'exemple
toujours de sabonis qu'est qu'un
attaquant
excellentissime mais il ya aussi
d'autres contraintes défensif qui est
rennes avec est lui-même n'est pas assez
fort en attaque tour pour être
transcendant et pour qu'on puisse
construire totalement une équipe autour
du lait etc donc c'est vrai que oui
court terme il pourra apporter des
points long terme est-ce qu'il est assez
fort pour finalement être un vrai
franchise player être un vrai top 10
ndzié c'est moi c'est un peu ma question
crois
moi je rajoute qu'une question pour
hugues est ce que simone quéro arrive au
magic dewald c'est le meilleur porteur
de balle que tu vois
c'est le meilleur attaquant c'est une
meilleur scoreur créateur meilleur
porteur de bol ça dépend de comment tu
aimes tu as les insectes 10 coups de fil
est
par contre ils peuvent jouer ensemble
j'irai que j'ai beaucoup parlé de sa
création balle en main mais c'est un
très bon passeur anne guéro donc il ya
peut-être l'option l'idée qu'on a de lui
trou noir je faisais le live de la
semaine dernière on me disait c'est
mercredi à bari parker et marvin bagley
hi eric mais qui pourrait passer
derrière tous ces pots
td4 scoreur on a cette image là des
décès chez des numéros de hockey
lah ce mec là vous avez un mec qui s'est
passé qui a montré vraiment comme si tu
as passé à trois niveaux et qui accepte
de jouer sur pick'n roll alors il n'a
pas énormément faire doux et on peut
voir aussi un gars qui lorsque le
challenge faisait chaud le banc caennais
tenir le bon cap and data que je prends
le ballon je marque et quand tu veux
faire briller les créateurs et bien pas
de souci je donne le ballon pick and
roll je relis détruite où je peux pop et
peut-être à pikine pop et ça c'est un
point travail qui l'a 25 % dans max à
trois points leur pitch and putt donc
cette casse est faible et à développer
et il a accepté de poser des écrans du
ballon c'est peut-être un truc un peu
con banal qu'on peut dire mais j'aime
bien voir si un joueur accepte de poser
des écroulements du ballon sans être le
bénéficiaire à la fin de la balle et
comme je disais qu'en trois mois n'a
jamais accepté de faire que mark bagley
qu'on me parlait de l'exemple n'est
jamais accepté de faire tony bennett non
plus voilà
du coup des légendes opposable en piste
et à la fin c'est par là que sortir mais
mais que ses équipes il ya donc il ya
une mentalité là dedans qui m'intéresse
aussi je vois plus qu'un broker
d'isolation
je suis je souscris à à ce que dit
hughes je pense que je suis d'accord sur
le fait que c'est pas un futur top 10
non plus enfin c'est parce que tu as dit
mais par pur et qu'on a à guillaume
[Musique]
ben dans le chat dit pour maximiser
stoxx bank héros c'est bien oui
on oublie marqué le fun par contre on
dit ce bonheur merci à leur part merci
merci
c'est je pense que c'est quand même
toujours marque elf elle se met un
porteur de balle l'année prochaine
d'orlando pas du monde
parce que c'est un joueur qui fait un
les stats le 10 mai même quoi tu vois
orlando jouer s'est créé des
opportunités pour les autres maintenant
faut encore faut-il conclure ces
opportunités quoi pour les autres mais
mais c'est un joueur cas comme
exceptionnel marqué le faisons tous le
travail des autres du coup la finition
ce travail désormais des balayeuses
aussi tout à l'heure pour dire est ce
qu'on essaierait pas quand même une
dernière saison de voir si ce marque elf
oil il le valait pas finalement ce
premier pic de draft puisqu'on parle de
draft donc
bancaire au effectivement ça va
peut-être un petit peu enlevé le ballon
des mains de tes porter potentiellement
prix primaire au secondaire en même
temps selon moi et c'est un truc que je
partage pas forcément avec avec par
exemple une good autres membres du
podcast pour moi parle aux banques héros
il est à son meilleur quand il a un taux
d' usage du ballon assez faible et ccc
en tout cas soutenu par les stades cette
année à duke les matchs les plus
efficaces qui fait sauf march madness
genre la demi finale que north carolina
où il est vraiment il est vraiment
option numéro un parce qu'il ya que lui
en fait capables de faire la différence
ce moment là mais
c'est un joueur qui est capable d'être
efficace sans ballon et on parlait tout
à l'heure du style de jeu avec beaucoup
de hand of et c'est un joueur qui qui
augmente la valeur du porteur de balle
sur un dauphin du mec qui vient chercher
la balle c'est un joueur qui est
dangereux lui même par le band hero est
dangereux lui même donc dans ce style de
jeu là il s'intègre très bien et il
n'est pas difficile d'imaginer un
orlando magic beaucoup plus efficace
offensivement avec paolo gontero sur le
terrain à la place du coup plutôt d'un
wendel carter que d'un mot bamba
est ce que au niveau contrairement à
chet on a parlé
lui il jouit pas aussi par contre du
côté star power s'est déjà été dans une
université
très connu une équipe qui était sur
armés
qui ont voit dans sa façon d'être etc
c'est vrai qu'il ya eu cette interview
c'est guillaume qui le rappeler on l'a
pris pour parti clouds
donc voilà est-ce que lui déjà il n'a
pas finalement plus labit entre
guillemets du numéro un draft que chet
bas
psychologiquement moi j'aime bien mais
en fait ils l'ont tous un peu l'année du
numéro 1 de draft
aïe aïe vie aux longues rênes mais dans
des styles différents mais bonne chaire
hausse et
il est hyper concentré il n'est pas
émotif il est dans son truc et il fait
son truc et il a une commande grain même
à des niveaux encore plus haut il a
vraiment pas peur de prendre des grandes
et grandir jeu j'ai revu ses marges ces
matchs de march madness il est
impressionnant sur un manège vraiment
vraiment impressionnant
il est pour mon pays et pour moi
j'accorde une importance particulière à
ce genre de match et à l'attitude qu'on
les joueurs dessus il est concentré de
bout en bout et du coup parfois qu'elle
peut avoir l'impression qu' il n'est pas
leader mais lui il est en fait il est
c'est vraiment un leader par l'exemple
pour le goût cheech est il va peut-être
un peu plus ouvrir la bouche et pas trop
jabbari va l'ouvrir grand c'est sûr mais
mais selon les profils psychologiques
que tu as dans ton équipe bombanceros il
va pas gêner quelqu'un d'autre en tout
cas tu vois il va pas prendre la parole
à quelqu'un d'autre il va pas prendre le
crachoir il va faire son truc et qui
m'aime me suive en eau
hélas le la famille qui est dans ce sens
là aussi c'est qu'alors je sais pas si
c'est des parents sportifs venant là
dessus j'ai pas fais mon travail désolé
mais il a des parents qui ont toujours
dit vas-y du baseball n'ont peut-être
moi j'avoue j'ai gelé je les ai écoutés
par les parents mais j'ai pas regardé ce
qu'il faisait
et
les parents ils disent toujours la
priorité sur le coach simon gamins et
vous obéit bas vous avez droit de le
porter et on n'est pas sûr de la
starification de l'enfant comme on a pu
l'avoir parfois et des fois à tort on
rappelle denis comme agnone le pape a
été très présent et voulait faire de son
gamin de stars
là ils ont dit si vous fait chier vous
le portez et moi yao capable j'emmène
derrière et on est peut-être sur un
environnement assez serein pour avoir un
professionnel jean calcul base un projet
sportif n'est pas conseillée pour les
gens qui ont des enfants chez eux
encore près d'accord moi j'en ai 26
alors pour tous les coups de feu dans le
chat vous pouvez taper des enfants
je vais faire les sens et l'exorciste
arrive le
[Musique]
web aussi j'en ai
j'ai entendu une comparaison avec
carmelo anthony je crois que c'est
hugues que kaka ça du coup tu le vois
pas du tout comme première option
d'attaquants nba
ça dépend de ce que ton équipe et le
volume
[Musique]
est ce qu'il ya cette philosophie de
porter de belles principal d'une équipe
qui perd ou non il a beaucoup été
comparés avec ses belles kids un début
de saison a dû être haendel knicks 2020
2021 on pense à ce que t'en veut
derrière l'annexion quatrième à l'est
avec une équipe avec une philosophie de
jeu comme ça et moi je le vois un peu
plus passeur donc voilà voir comment tu
les entourent faut voir ce que tu
attends du lieu ou pas je pense que tu
peux construire autour de lui et est ce
que c'est vraiment un poste 3 ou c'est
plutôt un poste 4 mobile du coup parce
que carmelo était quand même plutôt 3
quoi est-ce que wanjiru il peut se
décaler à ce point en 3 ou non c'est
plutôt un 1/4 polyvalent pour moi après
c'est ma philosophie je m'en fous toute
attaque ce qui m'intéresse et qui tu
défends
je vais te dire que les ailiers nba pour
le contenir il faut qu'il soit quand
même à ses tanks et je vais te dire que
défensivement je me mettrais toujours
sur le mans bon retour de balle adverses
sur les postes d'ailiers esquissé balle
en main alors je veux dire ah oui pour
moi il peut créer bolland il peut faire
de recul il peut faire des pleins de
trucs comme ça quoi donc on l'a vu je
regarde pick and roll bonne quiero mark
williams tu vois un mec de deux 02 06 se
passe avec 2 15 ans au lait ou par
dessus par dessous passe directe new
look et c'est sa passe en retrait sous
côté hockey
oui c'est un peu c'est un poste 4 plus
offensivement mais qui peut avoir la
balle en main donc du coup du coup là la
comparaison avec du scandale là dessus a
du sens pour revenir à la comparaison
que je m'étais fait la réflexion aussi
assez tôt sur carmelo su beaucoup sur le
job step et le espèce de 2,2 gestuelle
qui est très propre par ailleurs pour
pour paulo il faut pas il faut remettre
dans le contexte carmelo anthony 2003
syracuse c'est un athlète extraordinaire
qu'on a sans doute jamais vu depuis sur
ce poste là et avec cette explosivité
dans les petits espaces donc héros
s'approche mais il n'est pas là à
carmelo c'était surtout il commence un
peu à père me l'a jamais eue
l'explosivité de de détente mais des
appuis d'une légèreté et d'explosivité
incroyable que les bancaires on n'a pas
ça alors ça
passe moins et que maintenant explosé
sur les petits appuyé par contre il ay
là il a une puissance qui est similaire
je pense qu est il à l'extraction way et
il a une arme qui développe sa puissance
c'est le film où il se plie nous va à
droite ou à gauche dans n'importe quel
sens et quand il est en difficulté il
utilise ça y est ça fonctionne très bien
ça ne fait pas mal de questions de sur
le le mix que ça pourrait donner entre
john entonna isaac et par l'autre band
hero est ce que c'est compatible bon
port c'est surtout pas du tout un qui
joue bien qui joue pas c'est compatible
dans le folklore du cool c'est bon c'est
vrai qu'on n'en a pas parlé mais lisa
qu'enfin il sait qu'un mec qui fait la
différence il me semble avant de se
blesser mais qu'était devenu enfin
vraiment élite de chez élite quoi donc
en plus c'est vrai qu'on a parlé de la
paire carter oil carter et moubamba mais
vient se rajouter aussi peut-être la
problématique du fisac qui était plutôt
poste 4 stretch mais qui peut c'est vrai
que je poste 35 ans
moi ça me choquerait pas devoir donc
héros est un idéal quand même temps sur
un mode de cleveland avec des grands
grands leaders métier plus avec
quelqu'un qui est très fort au sol avec
brooke héros avec quelqu'un qui est plus
sur la longueur avec isaac des
poursuivants et du coup si tu joues avec
eyes à caen 3 tu peux peut-être joué
avec wendel carter en 5 tu vois
et avec colantoni sur le banc les
fraudes pour d'autres cole anthony il pu
peut être en deux
sur quelques minutes tu vois qu anthony
en deux et ce faisant on marque elf et
sans
âmes ont donné faut des joueurs qui
shoote sur le terrain quand même tu vois
je vous donne
ma question est un peu là dessus du coup
c'était plus haut niveau du shoot du
coup on a bien vu leur en parler là il
ya au début de se dire on a quand même
une équipe top 5 des pires
au niveau du shoot exter il en est où
j'avais des questions sur la défense
mais il m'a plutôt du coup rassuré sur
son identité défensive et sur qui
respecterait en tout cas les consignes
du coach sinon sinon sanctions mais
c'était plus du coup au niveau du shoot
dexter
c'est un peu les c'est un peu les points
faibles que moi je lisais sur les sur un
peu sur les mots clés us que que je
voyais quoi
je te laisse pas de son secteur
ouais
j'aurais sur 32 me le remettre sous le
sous les yeux mais tu vois ta team en
trois tentatives par match 33 34% ce qui
est assez flagrant chez le joueur contre
la chouette shirt courrier dans les
corners il est très efficace on est à 45
sa profession dans les corners donc des
qui récupère la balle et que c'est en
fin de chaîne et qui n'hésite pas il met
dedans compter sur une situation big n
pop donc la ddt en plus dans laxe 26%
pourquoi pas ce cas beaucoup
d'hésitations que ça a joué porté par le
drive ce alors qu'il tentait parle mais
distant multi préfère attaquer et il est
moins à l'aise et ça un mec qui importe
le moment il reconnaîtra les situations
et qui leur offre aux frontières il y
aura peut-être plus ces gestes parasites
d'hésitation de un ou deux ballons au
sol et de ensuite pour les élever et ça
va fluidifier le tien et quand tu vois
que tu es à 40% à mes distances sur des
tirs très compliqué moi j'ai pas de
problème pour casse à force le terme est
un prénom le shoot à trois points se
fluidifie mais c'est le même problème
kawada carter juniors du côté de renault
do aussi c'est que c'est des joueurs qui
ont beaucoup d'hésitations parfois trop
effréné tu leur dit vas-y tu fasses on
va pas gagner énormément de matches pros
tayssir créer de l'habitude motrices et
avalé derrière attend après le
l'indicateur des lancers francs et pâte
à pain pour au niveau du shoot pur
banque rôles à 6 et les chiffres coûte
avaient à l'écran 73%
c'est pas top non
ses moyens c'est sa seconde près c'est
lié c'est correct
et tient pour me demander cible de tirs
cholet regardez vite fait effectivement
on est à 86 4% de catch and shoot
poolers mais c'est parce que encore une
fois c'est un joueur qui préférait aller
vers l'avant et quand tu te rapproches à
mi distance voilà on est à mecha 39% à
mes distances
et il est à 80% de tir qui sont créés en
poule up donc tu vois très bien que tu
as un mec qui va pas voir de problème
mais il ya des habitudes motrices un des
rares joueurs qui est plus à l'aise pour
l'instant pour club que pour faire de la
fin de semaine fans de catch and shoot
est il en faut la regarder le corner où
il est plus de 40 50 %
alexis quelque chose à rajouter pour
paulo où on passe au suivant
alex autres pas à 100 sûr c'est le boss
qui censure est carrément ça c'est ça
c'est ça c'est l'autocensure la saison
c'est cette phase nous vous prêtons
prend le pouvoir
on va passer comme je rappelle dans le
tchat ce n'est pas nous qui faisons le
choix donc je ne dis pas vous exciter
dire que kate sait pas et personne ne
sait donc on essaie de voir un petit peu
tous les niches haut possible et encore
une fois on n'est pas décisionnaire du
masi
encore
leur maillot
j'ai vu des maillots chattam migraine 34
magic déjà fait là donc les gazons ils
ont lâché sans rabal fr bas de 13 mois
j'ai vu des maillots mba perréal donc
est ce que ça vaut un truc dont je sais
pas
où on va on va
on va essayer de l'aider de kourou est
ce bien un quart d'heure sur jabbari
smith quand même parce que c'est un peu
l'impression le favori des des
américains
c'est un peu le nom qui revient de la
part des insiders assez souvent avec
tout 27 comment apprendre à cette
période là encore une fois mais perd
deux oui
bah là aussi
donc
jabbari smith forces faiblesses une
gueule tu es magnifique tu continues
enfin
c'est sensuel chez en vert grâce à petit
on est sur un profil hybride intérieur
4,5 c'est la grande question puisque
c'est un 4s que cinq défensivement lui à
terme il ya débat il fait pour un fan on
bon c'est ça c'est la question on est à
deux mètres 0
800 kg la moyenne viella de 11 c'est pas
déconner on est sur un joueur qui a
trois ans était à deux mètres 0 1 donc
on a une grosse on a une grosse
évolution physique la dernière fois par
un très fort pour l'adhésion eu 16 avec
l'équipe américaine lient jouer ailier
et on le post 3 styles mac album cheese
et maintenant ils jouent intérieur donc
la une en développement physique chez le
joueur qui est assez impressionnant on
assez peu de temps on rappelle qu'il a
un papa qui a joué alors à l'époque les
ailiers forts pouvait faire 125 kg et de
mettre 10 mai le papa john barry smith a
été ailier fort pivot pour des équipes
style toronto et c'est donc un passif
n'diaye je pense que le petit l'a bien
bouffer du poste bas à la maison il ya
une formation de carrière il a joué à
haubans dans la hesse ici c'est un gars
qui s'est démarqué il était patent du
aussi fort je pense cette année il se
démarquer par sa création de tir il a
vraiment mis des poules up sur la tête
de tout le monde de toutes les distances
à trois points à mi distance postaux
encore une fois jobs step c'est un
gâchis une très grosse bouche il est
très émotif parfait pour l'émotion de la
jungle d'auburn qui est anders explosif
avec bruce pearl tout le monde crie
personnes réfléchies on adore c'est
vraiment une ambiance n 6 est magnifique
et
peut-être qu est ce qui plaît autant
c'est que le plancher a l'air très
impressionnant tu te dis km qui tout
aussi bien et je suis très bien et de
billets et de cette taille là ça va ça
coûte très très cher qui défensivement
alors voilà y avait peut-être dix
commence avec alex entre lui et moi moi
je crois pense à switch habilité
personnellement mais c'est la grosse
question c'est à barry smith qui fait
peut-être dans sa valeur c est ce qui
peut tenir des extérieurs au périmètre
ou non est ce qui peut protéger le
cercle ou non pour moi à terme tu vas
mettre de la masse dessus et avoir un
pivot parce que je trouve que c'est un
très bon protecteur de sa clos niveau
lycéens il était excellent là dessus et
je trouve que c'est difficile pour lui
de faire les allers retours on a dit
l'essuie-glace corner un corner corner
un corner moyens prime de rota des
hanches les fameuses retard en envergure
et qu'il faudra qu'il faudra suivre
et après je pense que je peux jeter la
parallaxe a su le têt le défaut majeur
c'est que si un jour tu vas pas au
cercle et salutaire beaucoup reproché
c'est il tire énormément ok mais quand
tu mets du défi et ce qui peut poser le
ballon est terminée au panier l'attrait
pleuvait
offensivement je pense qu'il est
tellement fort
sur le tir et d'ailleurs les chiffres
reçus sont au lancer franc provoqué le
trouble il a même pas besoin d'aller aux
serbes pour provoquer des fautes
donc le jour où il ira il sera très très
efficace il sera peut-être pas très beau
à voir jouer ce sera peut-être un peu
chiant au niveau de d'une attaque de
mouvement mais il sera très efficace et
défensivement je pense que je suis en
fait je pense que je suis d'accord avec
toi mais juste on voit pas la même chose
pour moi c'est un stoppeur
de gros ailier pour moi c'est un c'est
potentiellement un stoppeur de vrais de
vrais gros initiateurs principaux et
effectivement il va pas faire l'essuie
glace parce qu'en fait il va défendre
l'option 1 il va défendre le pointeau
m'attaque sur le bunker attack est grand
que tu vois quand quand c'est janis et
son plafond il va pas défendre demande
janis en mai mais quand cette génisse
quand ces mêmes même luca tu vois qu'ils
aient pas qui est pas vraiment dans
leurs dents dont la vivacité vers
l'avant mais qui est plus dans le la
puissance et l'utilisation de du recul
loire pour moi jerry smith ça va être ce
joueur là défensivement en tout cas
c'est la meilleure version 8 même ce
serait ça et donc ça a beaucoup de
valeur mais comme disait guillaume tout
à l'heure un joueur qui n'est pas un
initiateur
probablement balle en main offensivement
c'est difficile de draft et tout temps
même l argument pour en tout cas il ya
plus d'arguments pour le draft et lui
par rapport au fit par rapport au
développement des joueurs sur les lignes
extérieures etc il ya plus d'arguments
pour lui que pour paulo alors que paulo
un plafond plus haut je pense il a moins
de créations balle en main du genre
porteur de balle et passings que banque
héros c'est ça il c'est un bon passeur
mais oui c'est pas dribbler quoi
d'accord d'accord c'était plutôt le
passeur limite tête de raquette parfois
mais mais papa le créateur de picanol
quoi il a fait de très bons amis l'eau
il avait un gros pivot il avait kessler
avec lui il a fait du bon un vélo il a
fait du bon lecture de deux prises à
deux outils qui arrivait parfois
mais
effectivement il va pas jouer du pick
and roll mondial fantasmant que kevin
garnett ce fantasme au moins on est très
très loin de ce fantasme après kevin
garnett quand il arrive à une vieille
les îles et 3 + plus kevin garnett de la
fin du coup mis récemment parce que là
tu le décris défensivement plutôt comme
une commun 3 quoi du coup tu parles de
stoppeur elie et c est le temps qu on
nous attaque c'est plutôt 4 quoi c'est
ça
ok voir les mines pivot est ce que tu
disais limite à terme si tu disais que
ce serait limite un pivot c'est pour moi
c'est là dessus que le des offres moi je
pense plus on compte pivot je le préfère
au drop il a pas pour le fera à auburn
parce qu'il y avait un énorme pivot mais
j'ai préféré ce à sa couverture de
jolies scènes en europe ce que j'ai pu
voir o'byrne en europe dans de la
protection en tant que protecteur
principal de l'équipe plutôt que sur les
ailiers et pour le coup j'entends elle
explique voileux yanis hockey luca pour
moi non pas ce que déclare change mon
action je les veux finir par terre en
tout cas fenerbahçe dès qu'un mec peut
faire la main droite main gauche très
vite explosif et l'obligé à tourner je
l' ai vu à chaque fois me tue donc l'ati
j'y crois pas sauf encore une fois si tu
es dans une défense hyper intelligente
où tu donnes une ligne et tu te dis bah
je vais faire des pas chassés pourtant à
la défense il peut le faire très très
bon
on
voit justement lui aussi au niveau du
charisme et psychologique on va parler
un petit peu et c'est le côté
grande bouche on va dire ça comme ça
voilà à quoi de poliez
et mais alors lui la grande bouche ne
fait pas forcément le leader on est
d'accord avec ça on peut se mettre
d'accord sur ça que c'est pas parce que
quelqu'un par accountemps que c'est
forcément un leader ça n'a rien à voir
est ce que justement il avait vraiment
cette attitude tout le temps de leader
numéro un alors défensivement oui enfin
en tout cas on l'a vu souvent c'est
taper dans les mains et c'est ce qu'il y
avait sur le côté un petit peu où je
suis capable de rassembler l'équipe
autour de moi quand ça tourne un peu
moins bien
il a mis les gros poulpes quand il avait
besoin d'un gros thierry lagoutte jamais
prêché avec des dégénérés quoi ils
jouent avec comme elle s'attelle t'avais
jasper t'avais wendell grint avait enfin
que des mecs fou est être le le mec
poser de l'équipe qui était halal
flanigan il était blessé c'était lui qui
devait être malade le le patron qui a
fait trois ans qu'ils estève à peu près
de co2 o'byrne est blessé et bruce parle
est un malade mental aussi
personne pour un peu calmé le jeu et au
jeu de qui grill plus forts à jabal
smith et mais là dedans mais c'est pas
que crier pour crier genre écrit là il
fait des vrais efforts genre derrière un
appel d'offres par exemple si tu le mets
contre le magic qui peut être très
chiant parce que je serai nov il a des
bras longs très agressif pour attaquer
le ballon ils jettent sur la balle
derrière il y casse donc que tu peux
vraiment utilisable it's blitz blitz et
met de la pression elle le fera très
bien donc agressif dans le vocal mais
agressé dans son basket aussi
défensivement
ils croyaient d'envergure du coup mike
smith
chercher mais j'ai une question pour
pour gaëtan
jeudi sur les matchs c'était difficile à
voir mais qui sait qu'il leader de
vestiaire au magic c'est quoi les
personnalités qui as qu'il ya que des
personnalités justement un peu de
suiveurs et dans ce cas-là jabbari smith
irait très bien parce que la
complémentarité psychologique c'est
quelque chose qui importe
vestiaires manche pour les retours la
route j'ai lu ta ta robin lopez qui
apporte beaucoup qui apporte beaucoup et
15 ans un peu grande gueule pareil qui
apporte beaucoup et après un peu sur le
terrain en fin de saison quand il est
revenu un peu foods et après call
anthony après est ce que c'est est ce
que c'est un bon leader
ça c'est les 5 à autre chose mais mais
en tout cas c'est lui que moi j'ai
ressenti
[Musique]
leader quoi sur est un peu ternes
strauss ou six terrains trop quand il
rentre c'est lui qui a imposé sur le
terrain quoi il la poésie parle tout le
temps il parle tout le temps aux galères
place défensivement il a replacé
offensivement fin même s'ils devraient
se parler peut-être à lui et
défensivement mais ça c'est encore un
autre débat mais mais voilà c'est un peu
les gars que moi j'ai repéré quoi
apprécié non plus des puces des profils
suiveurs comme tu dis peut-être que ça
peut ça peut marcher
selon les sources est plutôt perdu 2,15
wings panne ce que j'ai vu c'est ce que
j'aime scouting est pour toi aussi
j'avais noté c'est quoi au pied du coup
j'ai pensé en voie de formation et par
danser
c'est pas mal mais c'est pas s'est passé
mais c'est moins que c'est moins que
chet évidemment et paulo c'est près
similaire on n'en a pas parlé
churchill à combien ils montent jusqu'à
2 30 ou pas non non il n'ya pas être l
ombre à chet je crois qu'il a de tête il
à 7,5 donc de 25pts est ok
c'est pas mauvais mais bien il a un vrai
long cou pour rentrer dans les détails
la spéciale envergure ça le long cou et
des épaules basses donc le standing
reach est pas fou par exemple par
rapport à un joueur qui est à peu près à
sa taille mais qui a les épaules hautes
comme mark williams du haut standing
reach et à de
2,98 4 il a sept centimètres du panu qui
fait sa marque
et moi j'avais une question aussi au
niveau du parce que vous avez parlé de
danse bancaire ou un peu et que
apparemment j'appréciais ce fait du
poulpe lequel des deux est meilleur en
poule up et angel shot de manière un peu
général jabbari
meilleur shooteur
peut-être détroit comme la doudoune toit
a parlé le meilleur shooteur mag sur
m6 je pense que c'est tout naturel c'est
ce qu'à l'attaqué
il a déjà il a des chiffres absolus
enfin très bon par rapport à la qualité
des tirs qui prenait
c'est à dire que il a 42 % à 3 points
sur 5 tentatives et demi mais c'est pas
des c'est pas des trois points
tranquillou
pijet au coeur playoffs quoi
cédé trois points dure
rarement rythme presque
parfois après mouvement est en fait
souvent contesté ou semi contester quoi
et à mes distances c'est pareil c'est on
arrive sur rond sur des pourcentages qui
sont moyens en terme d'efficacité pur si
tu peux te fais que des mathématiques il
y a quarante et quelques pour cent ans
d'existence mais par contre il a une
main dans la tête tout le temps et
infantile et lille un shoot très haut
très équilibré il est capable de lille 1
faye de weck
extraordinaire qui fait que c'est
quasiment un contrat bhl et du coup pour
pour mettre des mauvais shoots en fait
c'est un bateau tu mets coeur c'est le
meilleur match maker
j'avoue que j'ai un peu j'ai un peu peur
j'ai un peu traumatique ans quand on dit
un joueur d'isolation qui m'aidait poule
compliquée qui s'appelle jabbari
j'applique les traumatismes moi mais du
coup non mais au delà de la blague une
vraie question derrière comment est-ce
que vous jugez son côté un peu
cérébrales sont ces lectures de jeu et
ses capacités voilà appréhender le jeu
ea dans le moment parce que le gabarit
parker c'est un peu ça qui manque et
finalement comment est-ce que jerry
smith lui se débrouille de ce côté là
quel est son potentiel ans
sur le jeu cérébral
défensivement moi je le trouve un peu
flemmard du bol je trouve que le second
rideau il fait peu d'efforts il te dit
pas prêt il jouait il dit tout en
attaque et joue avec walter castor qui
avait le but de contrer tout le monde
donc voila mais défensivement il ya des
fois où je fais pas les retraites ou par
contre sur les lectures de défense de
pick and roll il vraiment très agressif
il vit très bien alors rien de très bien
il parle très bien et offensivement il
est prêt il bouge bien loin du ballon li
se repositionner dans le corner je
remonte à 45 degrés parce que je sais
que ce sera là et met en ligne deux
passes donc il ya une bonne lecture de
jeu trop victime donne qui est aussi
ligne de fond donc ça j'aime bien
non c'est mieux pour moi il n'y a pas de
n'ya pas de commune mesure avec serait
ce qui vaut déjà réparé car évidemment
mais même avec avec des joueurs qui sont
vraiment pas très intelligent
pour moi il est en fait c'était
difficile pour lui de cet environnement
n'a parlé dans notre podcast mais à
wimille est pas encore sortie
qui est en fait de prime abord ça a
l'air d'être un bon environnement parce
qu'il fait ce qu'il veut il prend des
shoots etc mais en fait il ya il a quand
même une ligne arrière qui est
catastrophique et donc la plupart du
temps les shoots qui prend il est
presque obligé de les prendre parce
qu'il reste sept secondes sur la
possession il et on lui file la balle et
on dit d'asie des maires de toi mon
grand donc donc en fait il là il a un
peu fait son mieux j'ai trouvé et il en
est altruiste mais et servir le choûtot
on verra ce qu il le fait parce qu'il
est plutôt réticent parfois
deux je vais demander à uc à lui plus de
matches que moi mais moi sur ce que j'ai
vu il n'y avait pas de réticence à
partager le bol donc non on est à peu
près un portage de la gonfle mais comme
tu dis c'est un peu là la meilleure
menace donc la fin enfin la balle à lui
revient et il aime bien provoquer de la
faute donc aussi 6/10 qui a pas d'option
bas je balance les bras et je saute
balance les bras et je vais te faire
tomber des fautes à mi distance donc ça
reste une bonne option et et en nba il
devrait voir des coupes dans ses notes
sur ok
une question juste niveau potentiel
c'est le meilleur attaquant des trois
noms pour moi
je pense aussi que ces bandes chéreau
met
mais il ya tout le monde n'est pas
d'accord dans notre équipe là dessus
manu l'aiment beaucoup du port ce qui
peut créer plus petit peu après c'est
vrai que tu penses tu de cette sueur
c'est vrai que si tu lui donnes handle
mais enfin tu vois si tu lui donnes méme
admettons de meilleur scénario le handle
la progression en deuil de paul george
et bah du coup oui les hyper fort quoi
c'est une première option mais mais
c'est un scénario
qu'on n'a pas le droit de faire entrer
dans les probables parce que c'est ça
arrive à moins d'un pour cent des
joueurs ouais puis marque apple si tu
lui donnes comme shot ses marques
tu préfères tu préfères tu donneras
chute un joueur plutôt qu'un dribble moi
je trouve
ma connexion les beaux livres ouais
ouais je vois ce que tu veux dire
c'est pas
quelqu'un qu'on pense
je suis pas qu'on pense bio de ça est ce
qu'il est plus facile de prouver ce que
tu as vu plus de progression sur le tir
ou sur le dribble mois de manière
générale ouais moi je pensais plus
facile d'enseigner le dribble mais bah
disons qu'après tel exemple par exemple
de en ce moment là deux challengers tu
sens qu'il a appris des mouches de
manière assez incroyable ne l'a pas non
plus le contrôle adaptabilité en
mouvement que des dribbleurs naturelles
ont depuis toujours quoi mais voilà
brown c'est fantastique les progrès
qu'il a fait quoi de l'autre côté le
jump shot il ya aussi beaucoup avec
l'âge mais ça vient sur catch and shoot
notamment en plus de mieux en mieux
après qu'un joueur d'un coup c'est que
vous êtes à devenir un joueur de couleur
c'est assez rare relativement sinon que
c'est j'ai pas trop de réponses
effectivement de ce côté là
moi je pense que c'est en fait les
préférences motrices font que tu peux
devenir un bon joueur de catch and shoot
citer un joueur un shooter moyens on ne
va pas devenir une grosse menace
ampoules up alors que le dribble c'est à
peut-être un peu plus variable
même si si effectivement aller en haut
et que du coup pour baisser de ton de
ripd est obligé de changer
la motricité du bas du corps etc mais
mes jeux mais pour moi ya en fait c'est
une chose qu'on demande tellement à peu
de joueurs de progresser en dribbles
pour devenir pour avoir le dribble d'une
première ou deuxième option que c'est
difficile à évaluer eux
par rapport aux tirs où on va demander
ça à tout le monde quoi après il faut
penser aussi que les mecs qui arrivent à
progresser c'est parce qu'ils ont déjà
de base en rien un capital athlétique
d'agilité de fluidité de contrôle du
corps équilibre etc pendant que est ce
que lui john harris mintya un peu ce
capital physique de base
clermont ok bon pour moi clairement des
trucs pas d'accord mais si monsieur
juste que je trouve vraiment son dribble
trop rudimentaire quoi après ça c'est ma
philosophie moi tu ratera pas autant les
genres qui ont explosé d'un coup dribble
à moi dans leur carrière de jeunes ils
ont porté le ballon dans les affaires
rejeté parce que c'était plus assez
efficace pour l'équipe en développement
car pascal sac à me porter le ballon et
comment elle lui a dit tu arrêtes parce
que tu as à mettre des écrans et quand
je lui dis en fait c'est bien quand tu
poses le ballon au sol il a repris et il
a tout explosé là de suite
jabbari c'est un peu c'est pas
totalement ça mais c'est un peu ça il
grandit tard
alors je regarde et il était plus ailier
shooteur en il faisait 2 4 85 kg je les
ai pas vus autres ont eu 16 quand j'ai
regardé après c'est du 16 et je suis pas
remonter au niveau collège collège
français tu vois mais je n'ai pas vu
beaucoup porter le ballon et au lycée
c'est pareil je n'ai pas vu beaucoup
posé la main je vois c'était affreux
j'espère sera rapport évalue meublé par
exemple par beau dribble de velan mobile
et comment tu le cites hughes
alors je suis pas trop fan de dribbles
des vannes mobley je trouve qu'il a une
meilleure attaque mobley du au panier
jeu rôle parce qu'il a un spin move qui
maîtrise très très bien là où james
smith et plus à l'arrêt c'est plus un
joueur qui qui s'élève et tu le regardes
montée tu fais hawaï et montrent aux
définitions dessus mais je pense que sur
la comparaison sur le vraiment les
capacités dextérité ceux qui sont à peu
près similaires je en train me faire des
actions dans la tête 20 des actions
mental de deux essais c'est pas
déconnant la comparaison dans le dribble
c'est de dire qu'il est loin d'être un
joueur capable de créer avec la balle en
main pour le moment mais
est-ce qu'on finirait pas par parler des
deux autres qui sont dans le top 5
ivy et les nîmes chez denis chabot
surtout sheldon charge pense qui
intrigue beaucoup parce que
effectivement personne n'avait joué il a
commis tnt qui met pas pu ou pas voulu
jouer donc il ya un peu c'est un peu le
client mystère de cette draft est ce que
lui avec tout ce qu'on a pu voir de lui
en équipe nationale et c est ce que
finalement
il ya un monde qui existent où il finit
numéro un
non
mais parce que moi je suis un chat un
frileux si un diamant casque s kalex dit
le dit très bien sainte gemme le voit
capacités athlétiques que les capacités
et que le surtout la mentalité du jeune
homme te font dire que y'a pas mieux
pour reconstruire ton projet sportif
bâti va mais là ça implique trop
2-2 privé avec un jam ou que je vois les
les qualités athlétiques on pense qu'on
peut être vaincue sur les capacités de
scoring et le corps oui si orlando
charge un créateur balle en main en tout
cas un créateur collectif une première
option d'attac qui peut initier du jeu
je suis pas sûr grève sur lui au moins
c'est un gros point faible notamment sur
le le dribble et la capacité d'aller
vers l'avant là dessus mais mais je suis
un joueur pour le coup que moi je
maîtrise vraiment très très peu trop peu
c'est difficile pour nous d'en parler on
a vu peu de matches
même ceux qui ont vu beaucoup ils en ont
vu peut
donc oui effectivement sur ce qu'on a vu
c'est ça après tu as des dvd des retours
de cette année à l'entraînement à
kentucky où il y avait du passing en
progression selon les personnes qui
étaient là bas etc c'était panneau
après les personnes qui étaient là bas
était a priori plutôt favorable à
kentucky a priori c était sur le campus
et qu il avait marre il y avait michael
schmid halak qui favorable à portland
maintenant mais mais pas forcément à
kentucky
ouais c'est mike smith qui écrit voilà
c'est en plus ça en libre accès pour le
coup sur le site d'espn et pas beaucoup
de choses en libre accès est
intéressante mais il ya ça y est les
rapports des tops prospeed il écrit ça
il écrit j'ai vu jouer chez d'une charte
qui a très bien répondu à l'opposition
physique qui qu'il avait en face de lui
c'est à dire un entraînement compétitif
en 55 etc et qui réagissait bien à ce
qu'on nous envoyait au niveau dépasse
donc
sous-entendu c'est lui qui avait la
balle aussi ce qui est est ce qui est
déjà pas rien dans un entraînement de
kentucky où il pouvait y avoir plusieurs
portables et
et voilà il
évidemment schmitz l'a vu jouer
plusieurs fois depuis de nombreuses
années et il voyait une progression de
ce côté là
si la progression c'est qu'il ya travail
si à travail c'est à dire qu'il sait que
c'est son son chemin vers la première
option qu'il
peut devenir parce que parce qu'un
joueur qui shoote comme ça en poule up à
trois points à son âge à sa taille
je sais pas si on a dans l'histoire
récente y en a pas beaucoup
j'ai pour toi y'a un petit shoot est pas
39% à 3 points au college aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs
non mais celle d'un uncharted ils
foutent vraiment à 38% alors qu'il prend
80 % de pula coise et du cou ou est ce
qu'il foutait pas ce que vous dites
qu'il n'a pas joué de la saison
officiel de 26 les chiffres pré
pré-candidat corderie school c'est la
ligne high school ou high school et hey
you et fiba et vous vous souvenez de
quel était le dernier top prospects a
pas avoir joué de la cemac en turquie
mais avoir fait 3 de draft ça va pas
vous plaira c'était en 2011
c'était une escale terre qui avait pas
joué du tout de la sen à kentucky je me
rappelais même plus qu'était kentucky et
qu'avec il n'a pas joué du coup il avait
fait top 3 mais pardon je divague de
l'étranger lorsqu'on tichy rabaska gros
bâtards
superbe super parce que du coup c'est
quel genre de profil globalement t1
extérieur ailier qu'elle la création de
stark en gros c'est ça mais en fait il a
toujours eu le ballon en main parce que
c'était le plus fort mais en gros il a
la taille d'un 2 3 il faire à 96 ok il a
une envergure de deux cochons à 2 10-2
11 sacs des cochons ouais
mais plutôt une envergure de l'autre
animal qui a beaucoup d'envergure genre
ligne à fauchon
il a il un drive correct ouais hughie
fait le mime et en fait c'est marrant
parce que ils montent de fou vraiment
bas juste à les voires parce que c'est
rigolo allez voir les highlight de son
de sa dernière année de son année senior
au bout de 30 secondes vous allez voir
un espèce de alley hoop moulin à vent
qui
s'est passé puis si les moulins à vent
mais il va chercher la balle genre très
haut j'entrais dréau un truc qui qui
fait kiffer topten de l'année n'importe
quand il y est même donc je suis
impressionné que tu veux dire
mais c'est pas un prêt enfin il fait pas
explosif quand il monte c'est à dire que
et pourtant il ya pleins d'articles qui
décrivent ils disent le moment où celle
d'une charte d'école il ya une espèce de
1 les le sait plus qui écrit ça qui
écrit le gas d'avant je crois que seppi
d'iweb qui est pour moi le meilleur
draft ryder cup
existe sur la sphère us qui écrit le gas
de avance au de shannon sharpe c'est
quelque chose que j'ai rarement vu quoi
et donc c'est un athlète de fou c'est un
chat mais coeur de fou
et donc ce qui fait une base excitante
c'est aussi une énigme de fou finalement
bas pour nous oui mais je pense que pour
les frontoffice nba beaucoup moins en
fait ok c'est pour ça que pour moi il
n'est pas aujourd'hui la plus hype top 5
donc ça veut peut-être dire qu'il ya des
questions psychologiques etc aujourd'hui
dans ce qu'écrivent johnny dans ce
qu'écrit un sam décennies de dianétique
ya il n'y a plus vraiment de doute sur
lui dans le top 5 ou pas il serait +56
que dans le top 20 que lui dans le top 4
mais sur le potentiel
à mon avis il fait partie de ceux là
maintenant on sait très bien que
l'évaluation draft elle n'est pas que le
physique
des des joueurs qui peuvent jouer une
très peu joué ici qui se présente quand
même mais qui sont tous arrivent quand
même relativement souvent je pense que
le dernier en date d'âge guerlande
très peu joué que l'an dernier
mais il joue quand même un peu bohème et
alors il fait cinq matches et met ses
cinq matchs débutent saison contre les
facs pour rien donc oui pas vraiment
choqué tu vas chez dunlop nous connaît
en fait ça le problème c'est qu'il ya
peu de modes de jeu disponibles et les
matchs de disposer contre des équipes de
merde et là je veux contre des bonnes
équipes il n ya aucune image en full
match donc on met on fait un
rapprochement souvent un peu logique
entre les deux modes il a quand même dû
concéder deux équipes 10 n il a tout
pété nous on n'arrive pas à faire le
lien direct on a passé match entier
contre les jets pas sa nourrice
christien de contrôle il ya une jacques
a démis contre ces gros lisez ça qu'on
veut voir vers cité non mais c'est déjà
klein six essais c'est pas forcément
l'échantillon toujours fiable pour
évaluer des prospects parce que c'est
pas parfait par rapport à nba mais c'est
vrai qu'il ya toujours encore plus un
mystère sur des joueurs que tu vois pas
jouer quoi c'est un peu c'est un peu
terrible moi j'ai l'exemple dantec somme
qui avait tout péter sur un championnat
du monde 2014 qui rentrait dans les
défenses comme dans du beurre facilement
en tout et finalement on a vu que voilà
c'était pas forcément un échantillon
représentatif de la suite quoi donc
c'est lord ficultés d'évaluer des
prospects qui joue pas quoi déjà
clancy's c'est pas parfait mais si en
plus il faut pour la n 6 et c'est
compliqué
après je vous propose qu'on enchaîne
directement sur ce rallye à partir
d'autres questions sur sharp corp il
faut vous comme vous l'avez compris on
n'a pas énormément d'infos
pas pressée le star bien de la donnée le
le fin il n'y a pas de bruit juste pour
gaëtan il n'y a pas de bruit sharp ou
ivy à orlando
ils les ont voir qu'à août ils les ont
vus
ils sentent qu'il ya un mort quatre qui
a été fait avec ivy mais pas de
nouvelles sur champ je suis presque sûr
ivy j'ai vu passer le truc m'échappe je
sais aujourd'hui aujourd'hui c'était ok
bon bah tu vois j'ai j'avais la bonne
info mais le shark je sais pas
lucho dit dans le chat non donc je pense
que il est aussi bien informés
donc du coup
on va
enchaîner sur à lévis un petit peu quand
même on passe à autre chose
c'est toi qui décide mais après on n'a
parlé dit
commence à être un peu tard nous venons
alchimie on va se terminer je pense sur
les choix du second tour en plus si des
fois quand même assez intéressant
d'avoir des joueurs intéressants à ce
niveau-là 32 35 est-ce que gaëtan chez
temps c'est sûr ça c'est quoi le projet
pour se classer les garder ces fonds
pour ce qui reste des infos qui ont
circulé la part de la main
moi ce que j'ai lu après c'est pas john
hammond l'info pure mais les deux sont
transférables les parce qu'il ya des
pactes et il ya des packs à faire
notamment avec tyrosse il ya enfin les
deux sont transférables après j'ai pas
d'infos cure de ce qu'on va faire de
sange peut pas le tuer et les fans
accueillir trois roues qui ça poserait
un problème ou pas ces droits des plans
d'eau 3 c'est trop moi c'est trop pour
pour moi 3 c'est trop dans l'idéal tu
fais après tu vois selon la draft mais
dans l'idéal tu mets tu mets tyrosse
avec le 32e et tu gardes le 35 quoi ou
alors tu mets tyrosse 32 35 et tu montes
jeu pas je sais pas qui en fin de
premier tour mais c'était vraiment un
joueur intéressant tu remontes le
premier tour et
26 27 enfin tu vois un truc façon il
faut qu'on les change tyrosse il partira
ça ne sent rien à la fin de saison que
je pense qu'il nous faut deux roues qui
sûr et qu'on puisse et qu'on puisse
vivre un ou deux joueurs et ce serait
quoi le profil que vous rechercherez
tous des
shooteurs j'imagine du shoot lipper
piper je sais pas guillaume pour toi
c'est qui qu'a de la valeur à ce
niveau-là de la draft
je n'ai non mais des profils tu vas
adacore choix que tu ferais que
d'essayer de me piéger sur des dons que
je connaissais
je t'explique palais je connais pas la
draft était donc moi j'ai l'impression
de lire des noms d'origine sur football
manager mais
non en fait l'essai c'est toujours un
peu le même principe s'est vu le taux de
réussite tu vas chercher le meilleur
profil possible et en l'occurrence dans
ces zones là on se rend compte c'est
toujours un peu d des profils role
players qui passe un peu sous les radars
ou tu as tu envie de dire je vais
prendre un mois la décline portant
junior toujours de deux joueurs à
potentiel qui sont tombés finalement il
y aussi pas mal de valeur à aller
chercher deux des rôles players même qui
va de 1 minute 20 minutes par match sur
trois en quoi c'est pas déjà ça serait
une bonne valeur d'avoir un joueur de
rotation à cet endroit là c'est déjà une
réussite au niveau du pic cette fois ci
on a pris conscience
les gens disent le coréen dans le chat
ça va pas ou quoi
ici ils sont faits ils sont faits
embrigadé par ben kiffan de youtube mais
avant vrai ça se défend oui bien sûr
presque du coup il avancé de quel homme
et qu'elle rend lui le renne jeu
habituel moi de donner le râteau on va
te donner le 30e drafted le 25ème
drafted c'est un grand shooteur qui
bouge très très bien qui se retourne
très très vite kid et qui dégaine de
port tout cas pas grand chose d'autre en
magasin mais c'est un pyromane donc ça
peut ça peut être d'en tuer tu shootes
voilà si tu veux du mouvement loin du
ballon des flots pied tweetbot là-dedans
moyens suivants il vaudrait mieux
prendre des shoots ouverts sur ce sur
ses piques là parce que déjà calendal
carter et moubamba ne shoote pas alors
en plus quand il y aura russell
westbrook valeurs du foot autour quoi
il n'ya pas de d'énormes twitter il ya
qu il engagé
j'aimerais un jour j'ai posté bien
beau but
hugo biso
concept de gens sont venus là pour être
au plus près de l'info il ya guette du
beaune qui a fait un mort quatre hier
gaby breuil de michigan state et
l'ailier souviennent d'y expérimenter
des longs bras mentalité
et la mort cote dire avec ron game ron
était dans le jeu fait un article sur
les potentiels style frais md et brown
avait le profil statistique en tout cas
de deux de ses joueurs qui
réussissent à se tirer des rôles de
rotation nba alors qu'ils sont choisis
un peu plus loin généralement hockey
parce que ce que à 1000 jefferson se
présente à la draft encore c'est la
tuque vingtième année non il est là
autres jarreau signé pour son année
super super senior ok je crois que la
course avec perry ellis aussi donc il
est devenu coach pour lui
il est d'emblée à d
un des premiers assistants l'année
prochaine de jeunes chez eux
oui on nous dit christiane brand dans le
chat si des 132 tu peux le prendre en 32
athlétique shoot
vient de kansas bon c'est pas grave
champions sont champions monsieur dit
wire mais en plus ils vont se
spécialiser du coup dans les ailiers
longtemps et blanc quoi jean françois
est ce qu'on ne sait pas l'équipe avec
le plus de blancs en nba
palais crystal
bons joueurs en tout cas où l'équipe
avec la rivalité la plus haute de fac
d'albi puisqu'il ya la réalité et luke
adam chic mauvaise ne l'ait pas vu
arriver
réalité super star en rolls prg très
surpris
et cenon
vite vous venez sur dix cordes et on a
fait une liste de tous les deux tout
l'essuyer n'diaye mais qui m'a demandé
pour les veaux que ces journées lens et
25 c'est là dessus
que repasser au évoquerez les 25 donc
j'ai chiné vous faites votre marché
salue monde mon avis sur ronnie
david roadie c1 c'est un mètre cube
c'est un intérieur qui a joué owens de
collodi state qui fait tout très bien
avec un petit et je pense que l'info
allait demander parce que monsieur à
walcott ya quatre jours avec le magic
après audi pour pour compléter pour moi
c'est vraiment le genre de joueur qui se
fait drafté dans une équipe qui
fonctionne déjà bien etc a besoin de
role players à court terme pour pour
aller donner quelques minutes en saison
régulière puis en playoffs lakers où les
net's quoi
faut traiter les gens c'est nous pas
soit dit là il a mal mesuré aux combines
donc je pense que c'est vraiment il va
faire le tour re dit tu l'as vu au war
iv dont je les regarde john quinzaine
vingtaine d qui boucle c'est qu'il a
vraiment pas dû alors déboulé banza faut
combiner qu'ils essaient désespérément
de trouver son sport après moi je moi je
les aime bien bon moi je le draff facile
en 25 et 36 si j'ai besoin de ce profil
là je sais que c'est un joueur qui va
qui va être utile sur un parquet quoi
qu'est-ce qu'on a encore du et j'ai
l'île de wight
abbassi glisse oui mais pareil c'est
exactement le genre de joueur mais en
meilleur j'ai la gueule pour le coup
c'est les meilleurs shooteurs meilleur
défenseur que david redis très bon bras
et venant lit de
[Musique]
valider accordent elles
le chat en si vous avez des questions
n'hésitez pas c'est le moment après à
prévoir en scooter on a vite fait le
tour quoi effectivement dans l'intérim
et c'est pas sa spécialité non plus
wendell mort c'est pas sa spécialité non
plus
si tu veux vraiment mais normalement
c'est le rôle de colantoni enfin si je
ne m'abuse que je lui prédis à long
terme c'est à dire le gars de la seconde
unit qu'amène du punch offensif de la
création sur le terrain
il ya hugo besson qui va être dans ce
goût là
mais pareil je le préfère dans une
équipe qui fonctionne déjà bien
donc ouais c'est pas une draft à shooter
c'est qui ce shooter de dieu que hadji
griffin il va partir plus tôt si c'est
un nom à
ce point
à 40 sauf si sauf s'il ya une
catastrophe sur son dossier médical
d'accord donc
voila mais sinon c'est pas une race
tâche routeur et mais après ouais non il
robin lopez il s'en va gaëtan
way ou alors ils vont le signer dont ils
vont lui remettre une année au minimum
vestiaire et mes
par un backup fight ça peut être sympa
même si tu draft chilton grain tu vois
tu peux avoir un backup five qui fait du
fait du cercle à deux cercles et qui met
des coups quoi il ya orlando robinson et
je trouve ça drôle d'avoir orlando à
orlando
et ses 1,5 qui peut stretch le malawi
est pertinent monsieur hors des points
drôle pertinent
et wii aura les dents pivot il y aura
des kamagaté il y aura des canevas diop
yannick enzo peut-être fois le quart
kessler le pote de dja paris qui sera
dispo
aura plein de pivot disponible aussi le
front office du magic a envie de ça
c'est vrai critère de choix c'est plus
ce qui est c'est plus fischer gros big
up a surtout en second tour a priori
c'est vraiment larzac qui aura du choix
32,35 tu prendras tout ce qui va glisser
dans l'idée je suis quand même plutôt
d'accord il ya déjà tellement de jeunes
à développer soit tu crois un gars vieux
tu vois quel âne grady tu sais ce qu'il
va faire il va shooter c'est tout
soit tu sois tu les drass pas quoi faire
franchement oui aussi de mourens tâche
s'ils n'arrivent pas à trop vrai ouais
le staff est beau ça fait beaucoup de
monde
- chicago vous affichez vous êtes
d'accord tortue mureaux comme sa
discrète au sort enfin introduire et
escudé des profils à la mare stephen
hunt ce genre de délier un peu de
deuxième tour où un nombre à fêter
est-ce que ce qu'il y en a un peu dans
cette zone sont intéressants ou pas moi
j'adore j'adore quenelisse d'alabama
dans ce style là qui est long qui défend
et qui pour moi un peu sous coté au tir
quoi
jabari walker g à paris moi j'écoute
kebab
s'il longueur et 4 polyvalence défensive
il peut il peut se placer là quoi tu tu
le mets au soleil pour le faire fondre
tu mets une broche un jour de beau
justin libris de
kevin mccall art voilà ce genre de
genre de profil là effectivement qui
peuvent être limités en draft aide mais
mais grâce à leur défense vont
vont parvenir à peut-être se créer une
petite place en nba et est ce que dans
cette zone ils ont un potentiel crise
middelton un mec ac kaka du scoring
comme ça de création mais qui est passé
sous les radars qui étaient blessés ou
qui pour exploser à ce que vous allez
une wild card de deux créateurs de mon
niveau dans cette zone il me voir et est
ce que tu veux arriver avec un tu vois
les brawns aux parents ou pas arrivé
là la non mais c'est pour alex parce que
chacun cherchait depuis un an il ya un
joueur que moi je top 10 et qui va
sûrement être deuxième tour en trois
petites secondes si brawn que je vais
passer à chaque live est une sorte de
deux agresseurs de cercle exceptionnel
tient un dribbleur fou qui a pas de tir
qui défend pas mais qui qui arrivent a
marqué 39 points 52 minutes sachant que
tu sais qui va aller au cercle et qui
marquent quand même 39 points 52 minutes
j'ai aujourd'hui de rêve sur des russell
westbrook lidl justement au complet pour
pour ouais moi je ne me lasse pas du
web et qui a une si state il avait pas
de pivot il avait pas de shooter et il a
pris le bail avec arkham city n'avait
pas d'autres coéquipiers il a pris le
ballon il a dit bah je vais marquer il a
fait ça toute l'année
tu es resté roadson quoi
j'ai pas la réf mais
dans ces cas rien faire une bise
on peut être là dessus
je te fais confiance
mais wade slasher comme ça il faut si tu
as envie de tenter le coup mais je pense
pas que ça soit l'équipe pour
ce que tu vois il ya quelques porteurs
junior à quelques années qui était
descendu comme ça où est ce qu'il est ce
qu'il ya des mecs un peu qu'ils étaient
attendus très tôt qu'ils peuvent
descendre dans cette zone là après il
n'est pas descendu si bas quand même
130 pompiers pizza quand même un était
attendu top 10 top 15 ans je me souviens
de qui tenir sur des beach boys tonnes
horner qui sont obligés boston ça compte
patrick baldwin cette année
mais qui shoote c'est un shooteur
shooter shooter c'est un plot shooter
mais sinon
était attendu vraiment top 10 il ya des
joueurs qui était attendu pas loin il ya
des bras et smack go and et peyton
watson voilà qui était attendue plus
l'autre yves top 20 et qui peuvent être
quasiment une draft est pour le coup
parce qu'ils ont fait une année de merde
mais je pourrais sma guen je pense pas
mais bresse maïwenn ce pour moi c'est ma
grosse cote d'un gars qui peut devenir
un scoreur d'une mauvaise équipe on a
bon monsieur je vous propose qu'on
arrête là toute façon on alex en tout
cas est de retour demain tu vas y avait
que qui demain non on déconne ah
non c'est pas demain mais quand vous
non c'est pas de nom on a des gars te
prévenir
nantes
le prochain prochain rendez vous le
prochain
vous m'entendez pas ouais ouais le
prochain le prochain rendez avec toi
c'est la semaine prochaine avec toi
avec portland ok on va parler de
refondre savoir ce qu'ils vont faire de
leur pic
7,8 je sais plus là comme ça ça va il ya
des rumeurs
avec l'épisode
il ya machine est ce qu a révélé que
peut-être que finalement ça se décide à
le garder aussi
du band qui dit qu'il ya encore
quelqu'un qui arrive dans le staff pour
les blazers ce qui bouge un petit peu eh
ben on va remercier
gaëtan et guillaume merci beaucoup
d'être venu
gaëtan qu'est ce qu'on te souhaite à
park est temps a compris tout le bonheur
du monde et comme autant de moments
[Rires]
ouais je pense que je pense jet
set et pour vous alors que que chet se
développe bien peut-être il me dit
où est ce qu'on peut tourner pour
trouver ce que tu allais n'est que par
rapport aux podcasts
basket un fou au web sur parce que
tinfos sinon suivant sur twitter je fais
des podcasts et assez régulièrement donc
je sais pas trop ce qui en ce moment
mais si je crois que j'en ai un sur evan
turner qui va sortir bientôt d'accord
scouting vintage justement
[Musique]
on te souhaite quoi toi
six jours de semaine et de tenir ma
pomme
exactement et de poids mais remettre des
tartes aux enfants c'est à cause de
soucis n'ont jamais
j'ai pas devra d'ailleurs regarde
non
c'est ça
et puis alex
qui a philosophé magnifiquement au mont
rose
merci souhaite une bonne connexion on
parce que là je crois je suis en train
de vous perdre ouais donc il est temps
d'arrêter ses sabots outils à très
bientôt oubliez pas de vous abonner
comme d'habitude vous pouvez lire et
partager vous connaissez les balles
comme on dit allez des bisous cobayes
merci les gars chaud